hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before just before just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast
uh what's going on how are you
uh I'm just checking in on you and all
that [ __ ] um
I think I'm finally getting over this
[ __ ]
whatever the hell I had
I think I had a touch of Ebola you know
what I mean we just do like a wee-choo
shot
a [ __ ] wheat juice
um I think I had a little [ __ ] Ebola
in there man
um
stupid I'm the worst when I get sick I
just keep you know
plowing ahead like an [ __ ] my wife
just sits there going like you need to
lay down
you need to lay down you need to take
this and just lay down and then it like
bothers me because she's telling me what
to do
right so then that stupid part of my
brain that doesn't want to listen to
people when they tell me what to do even
if they're giving me good information
causes me to be like yeah I'm fine
I'm [ __ ] fine
I can tell you this right now man
don't ever have turmeric in your life
and then go go commit a crime because
you're going to leave a [ __ ] Trail
I mean that [ __ ] just it ended up on my
I had it down in the kitchen it ended up
on my bathroom towel
I went on the internet and I got one of
those stupid [ __ ] um
you know recipes take some garlic and
some lemon and some turmeric and some
[ __ ] honey it's got to be all natural
honey
make this concoction and ginger and boil
it all up and all of this [ __ ] you know
oh no I didn't do the turmeric one I did
the one with the orange
and then
um see how it worked then somebody else
made the turmeric one
and Son of [ __ ] did I
well I know what happened I spilled a
little on the floor
and I just took I was in the bathroom
because I went upstairs to drink it and
then I put it on my towel and I was like
look my towel was glowing
I'm like what is that it looks like a
highlighters on it I found out it's
turmeric which evidently is really good
for you liver
especially after you did like five
nights in a row of Nyquil
which is like taking you know George
Foreman body shots without blocking them
I guess to your liver for like five
nights in a row so
um
I don't know I don't know what the what
the hell this thing is but I think I'm
finally past it
um anyway
it's nice uh
it's nice to sort of be back and I go on
the road tomorrow
right or today when this thing's coming
out right oh my goodness
I go to Jacksonville Florida
right
that's every most people when they go to
Florida they go to Miami
or they go to Tampa not me I go in feet
first if I'm going to Florida I'm going
to Florida
all right I'm gonna go to the part of
Florida that scares most people that
live in my city
I'm gonna go to Jacksonville Florida
should be an easy show now that Trump is
you know
starting back up again
um oh God that [ __ ] asshole's coming
back that means Joe Biden's gonna win
again
Jesus can we get can we get away from
these two [ __ ] people this is like
the two of them are like when Freddy
Krueger and [ __ ] you know uh Jason
started making didn't they do that
Freddy vs Jason
and you know one of those movies you're
like who the [ __ ] am I supposed to be
rooting for you
um
anyway
um so I'll be dealing so anyway they
will be in a good mood
so that's that's good
um and then you know who doesn't want to
be in Florida
this time of year what East coaster
doesn't want to be in Florida in like
November you know starting to get cold
up no oh wait I live in Los Angeles you
know what I do I don't
because I'm already living in that
weather actually you know what I do like
about living in La is going to Florida
like Jacksonville is a it's straight
shot
you literally just get in the airplane
and he gets over the 10 and he follows
it
from LAX in Santa Monica and follows it
all the way to Jacksonville do you
realize that
how long that goddamn street is
or a highway I mean that's that is
[ __ ] insane
that people did that
that they all got together
you know
I'm sure Native Americans had something
to do with it or uh you know
black people that didn't get credit I
have no idea at some point they'll make
the the True Hollywood Story about
whoever built the [ __ ] 10 freeway
[Music]
um
anyways but how about the Bruins and the
Celtics
all right it is football and basketball
season and who has the hottest [ __ ]
arena in the league that would be the
tdf Bank North Garden Illuminati
Bilderberg Center where the two of them
play Bruins 14 and 2 baby
um rapidly approaching their greatest
start ever from 1930 whatever
um
I heard what's his face Jack Edwards say
it the other night it was 1930 something
we started off at 19 and two
um
we have 14 and two Celtics have pretty
much a similar record
which is great with the Fiasco that
happened with their coach who's now
suspended it's great to see that we can
just [ __ ] hit the ground running
and uh let the Two Jays and everybody's
just
moving right along it's [ __ ]
fantastic
um you know not like these other states
in cities that need like 52 [ __ ]
teams in each goddamn sport couple two
three here two over here one over here
we got we got four one in each sport and
they all [ __ ] win it's fantastic it's
fantastic
one starts loose and the other guys pick
it up
it's been an amazing run so I was
thinking you know I don't think
anybody's ever won a Stanley Cup in an
NBA championship in the same year
in the same building I know they've gone
to the finals because uh the Bruins and
the Celtics
the Celtics were in the NBA finals and
the Bruins were in the Stanley Cup Final
or is it the other way around I always
forget
um
in like the late 80s
it was into June and it was so hot in
the building because the old Boston
Garden did not have
um
air conditioning
and I remember the ice was all slushy on
purpose because we were trying to slow
down the Edmonton Oilers there was
literally like fog it was a marine layer
over the uh
oh there was so much humidity above the
ice that when the air came within
content contacted the ice the air was
then cooled to its dew point to the dew
point which is when moisture becomes
visual visible I still remember that
from my Private Pilot test
um
and that's when my uncle Glenn Wesley
just shot it over the crossbar I
remember that one then you had that uh
who was it
that Reagan Reagan the [ __ ] was that
goaltender
um
anyway
they're doing great and how about that
call I made Monday night
the Commanders
not only did they cover 11 points they
won the [ __ ] game
and that's good for all those old ass
Dolphins who want to [ __ ] celebrate
like you know nobody's broken their
[ __ ] record yet which is the
stupidest thing ever
um
you know it's like nobody ever is
because
it's just to tie their record now get
you out of the regular season I think
it's one of the sillier [ __ ]
things out there but you know if that
helps those old guys out I guess that's
all right but I was rooting for the
Philadelphia Eagles to do a root for
somebody to do it
um but then I think that then what
they're going to do for the rest of
their lives is now that's strategic the
tradition
is that you gotta like hate on the the
younger players or whatever whatever the
[ __ ] that is
um that would be like me being an old
comedian
you know and if you had like the most
successful stand-up special of all time
you know every time a comedian put out a
special and it wasn't the more
successful than yours you'd like drink a
little bit of champagne
um sorry I'm still on a lot of [ __ ]
cold medication right now
um I golfed on Monday
I had a great time
with uh Andrew and Peter
from uh was it louder that clothing line
I had a [ __ ] blast with them it was
just fun watching them play they were so
goddamn good
um and then there was another guy uh
Tommy irons we were calling them because
once he switched from his clubs to his
irons he started smashing the [ __ ]
ball off the tee
um had his own Winery
you know and I get golf you meet all
these [ __ ] interesting people and
what they do for a living is really
interesting and then you you walk around
and just give each other [ __ ]
joke around and all of that stuff and
break balls
um I don't know where the carving up the
United States happened but it definitely
does not happen out on the golf course
at least as far as my experience
and listen to this Oh Billy freckles was
out there
um I played terrible even for me like I
forgot
how I had you know mastered my own
little Charles Barkley swing but uh
someone was nice enough to take a
slow-mo video of it and oh my God it's
it is a thing of ugly
you know
um it's sort of a smoothed out Charles
Barkley but at least Barkley goes all
the way back
um
but I don't stop at any point uh anyway
uh
play 18 [ __ ] holes I got through 15
and then I had to leave because I had
some [ __ ] to do with the movie but
um I had a [ __ ] blast
and um
we were playing out in Camarillo and
we're right near the airport
I've flown out there had lunch out there
a million times
flying out there and it was really cool
to see the airport
you know from that golf course I'm
always flying over it to be on the hill
and looking down at it and [ __ ]
and a great bunch of people
uh comedy gives back is the name of the
uh the charity and um
but anyway I had to take off [ __ ]
early but um
I gotta be honest with you again like I
just I don't know if I got it in me I
can do nine holes 18 holes is just like
I don't know you feel like you're on
jury duty you know
um
I will say I was amazed though
and how well those two guys from louder
were just [ __ ] crushing the ball
I mean just straight
a mile anytime they wanted to
um
you know I felt like I was watching ESPN
highlights it was [ __ ] awesome
um so anyway I'm getting geared up here
to do some shows
gotta make sure I [ __ ] rest the boys
there I have no idea what's going on in
the world so this should be [ __ ]
interesting
um
still haven't smoked any cigars no soda
no weed my coffee is off the [ __ ]
rails I mean you got to do something
right
you know usually I would be going to the
gym but I just been I've been doing this
all [ __ ] week
um
you know it's funny I borrowed my wife's
car
and
she had on a playlist she had this this
artist Bia Bia
Bia
and I started listening to it
and the drum tracks were really cool and
she was like [ __ ] hilarious then I
found out she was from Massachusetts and
I downloaded the album and I [ __ ]
loved it I've been listening to that
like Non-Stop
um
it's kind of funny like some of the
funniest women out there are like
rappers
you know Bia Bia is that he said cardi B
Megan the stallion
you know I was my wife listens to all
that in the car I was just listening to
this stuff and I was [ __ ] cracking up
[Music]
um
and the drums are great too you know
it's all this weird [ __ ] that a human
being wouldn't think to do I feel
um
and I also feel like it's a cardi B song
for drummers out there download that one
money
and it's got these hits right in the
beginning just on piano with a little
bass drum underneath it it's on the one
next bar it's on the two and then it's
on the one and it's fun to like
solo so try to solo man can't do that
but like in between those and then
coming out on those hits
is uh
I don't know I find that a little more
fun than of listening to a [ __ ]
metronome
um so anyway let me uh let me do a
little bit of the [ __ ] reads here
uh Jesus Christ here's another phone
call hang on a second
all right I'm back I'm back gotta take a
quick phone call there
um anyway oh you know what I did last
night I watched the [ __ ] highlight
reel of dick dick butt kiss
holy [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] joy that was to watch
um
talk about a guy who could play in any
era
um
I I haven't I haven't watched a dick
bucket's highlight reel in a long time
and it was just [ __ ] it just took me
back to when I was a kid there was
something about those highlights
from the 60s
and the color and that so that NFL film
is just like and then also it's right
before those cookie cutter stadiums got
made
and like you know the late 60s early 70s
a lot of them you know and uh
you see like teams playing like baseball
stadiums and [ __ ] like baseball stadiums
that don't even [ __ ] exist anymore on
like someone like two levels it's like
the football team
is playing in the baseball team baseball
stadium that no longer exists
and just watching that guy
on every play just beating the [ __ ] out
of people
you know whenever I saw ndamuka Sue play
and get in trouble and all that like I
never felt he was like a dirty player I
just looked at that guy like that guy is
playing in the wrong era
like I'm telling you if you you anybody
out there who's good at like
um
you know splicing [ __ ] together you
could make a video of Dick Butkus
Sam Huff
uh uh uh
uh Deacon Jones
all of those guys
all right the Fearsome Foursome the
purple people eaters doomsday defense
you could drop in damakasu right in
there with the same [ __ ] music and
other than the the turf that he's
playing on and how glossy it's gonna
look
um that guy would fit in
like that [ __ ] where he stood when he
got up and he stepped on that guy and
people like oh my God
it's just like
I mean that was just how it was done
you should really watch some of those
old NFL films if you get a chance
specifically the Oakland Raiders
of the 70s the soul Patrol and those
[ __ ] guys
they like they didn't want to break up
the past they wanted you to catch
the ball so they could basically assault
you
um
one of them like they would they would
you'd be running out of bounds and a guy
would just he had like a cast on his
army would just come all the way back
and then just
his tackle was he would just for him
smash Society ahead and knock you out
um
speaking of which somebody was showing
me Dana White just bought some League
of you know those videos where people
just stand there and they let each other
slap each other
like that's gonna be like uh
a new sports league and like the
gambling potential of that
is like right up there with drag racing
which was one of the easiest things I
ever gambled on
I remember going to it and this guy
would just be standing up and everybody
in our section was gambling and he would
just point to one side of the track and
people put their money on that one and
then pointed together and you just you
could just sit there and gamble all day
and sit in the Sun and [ __ ] drink
beer you're gonna be able to do that
with this slap Fest whatever the hell
they call
um my only thing uh is I hope those kids
the people who are doing that
put an ear plug in or something
because if somebody slaps you that hard
and catches your ear boxes your ear your
[ __ ] eardrum is going to explode I
would think you know me
you know most people are about the CTE
right now I'm about protecting
protecting the ears everybody's trying
to protect the brain now I'm I'm not
um
anyway
um
decided to look into uh
oh Karen bass becomes first woman
elected as Los Angeles I thought she
already was the mayor
I had no idea
oh so LA's Giuliani didn't get in
Giuliani meets uh
Bloomberg
um
oh my God Donald Trump is back Jesus
Christ just when you thought it was safe
to go on Twitter
oh God do we gotta listen to the
Liberals [ __ ] whining slash helping
to promote the guy
um
anyway uh
I will tell you this I am going to
[ __ ] ignore this election like
you know our relatives coming to the
town that you don't want to [ __ ] see
not even a relative I actually get along
with my relatives let's let's [ __ ]
frame that better let's say uh I'm gonna
love my wife's friends all right let's
just say my wife
had somebody who was a [ __ ] loudmouth
[ __ ]
you know what I mean and then had
another friend who was started to say
something and forgot what they were
saying in the middle of it just imagine
if they had both of them over the house
for [ __ ] two years
I would definitely figure out a reason
to go out to the garage let's put it
that way
um
anyways
oh [ __ ]
um
oh Jesus Christ
look at them just still going after Dave
Chappelle here what the [ __ ] you know
what I mean it's unbelievable they leave
the FDA alone they leave pharmaceutical
companies alone and they just will
[ __ ] turn oh don't try to turn over
every [ __ ] Stone they can
um I've you know I saw that monologue it
was [ __ ]
it's a great monologue
yeah it was measured like what is the
problem it was jokes
[ __ ] unreal
you know you would think the guy came up
with synthetic heroin and got people
addicted to it a bunch of people's
relatives died you think that that's
what happened
um all right let's do some reads here
um
Helix everybody helix
Helix sleep is a premium mattress brand
that provides Taylor mattresses based on
your unique sleeping preferences the
Helix lineup includes 14 unique
mattresses 14 like Steve Brogan
including a collection of luxury models
huh a mattress for Big and Tall sleepers
and even a mattress made just for kids
so how will you know new how will you
know which Helix mattress works best for
you and your body take the Helix sleep
quiz and find your perfect mattress in
under two minutes and your personalized
mattress is shipped straight to your
front door free of charge Helix knows
that there's no better way to test out a
new mattress than by sleeping on it
uh in your own home that's why they
offer a hundred night risk-free trial
try out your new Helix mattress see how
your body adjusts and if you decide it
doesn't it's not the best fit you're
welcome to return it for a full refund
gross uh plus Helix mattresses are
American made yeah [ __ ] me right in
the old [ __ ] USA
and come with a 10 or 15 year warranty
depending on the model
I think it depends if you're not like
you know like thrashing around in the
throes of a
you know if you're kicking heroin in it
and you sweat all over it you probably
knocks off five years right and remember
you get to try it out for a hundred
night risk freeze if you don't if you're
risk free if you don't love it I know
you will but if you don't they will pick
it up for you and give you back a full
refund what is there to risk you try it
out if it's not the best night's sleep
you ever got you [ __ ] give it back to
them
thanks for letting me try it out
right
you can't do that with a pizza uh don't
want to take my word for it Helix has
been awarded the number one mattress
picked by GQ and Wired Magazine it's
even recommended by multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine as a go-to solution for
improving sleep Helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com with Helix better sleep
starts now
and I'll tell you right now if you get
one of those mattresses lay off the
[ __ ] coffee whoa
um anyways Bruins got the Flyers
the filthy [ __ ] Flyers
um I was watching some of their
highlights the other uh the other day
remember when Chelios elbowed that guy
in the [ __ ] head
on the Flyers
and uh send them to the uh to the
infirmary and then a few games later
Ron hackstall came skating out of the
[ __ ] goal
and attack Chelios I mean those were the
days
those were the days and you knew when
you were there
um
here's the thing I signed up for the
center rights package and all of that
[ __ ] is it me or you know I used to sign
in on nhl.com and I could [ __ ] watch
the games but I feel like because
they're on ESPN I'm not allowed to do
that anymore
am I nuts can somebody [ __ ] uh
twiddle at me or uh insta instagramy
Instagram at me
um
by the way I'm getting excited uh and
I'm getting nervous
um I got my pickup trucks coming
all right my little Christmas gift to
myself I ordered it [ __ ] months ago
and this complete absolute [ __ ]
horseshit that there's not enough
computer chips is just one of the
biggest lies I've ever heard in my life
like why are there not enough computer
chips
it's just like the oil companies oh they
did they just stopped producing it
you know so now the price is going to go
through the roof and then whoever's
president is going to get [ __ ] blamed
for it you know
it's like why aren't there enough chips
um I think that they're just getting
something about CarMax and people
ordering cars online I think they're
trying to phase out or what how the way
Tesla Sells Cars I think they're jealous
of that so now they're acting like
there's this [ __ ] shortage and there
isn't
and uh that's my I think the the future
is when you go in to buy a car there's
just going to be one price no salesman
everybody gets [ __ ]
and you order it and we'll talk to you
we'll get your money immediately and
then we will talk to you in about six
months I think that that's how it's
going to go down I think that's that's
the way that they want to do it
um
and if they made jokes about that and
did a monologue as a stand-up comedian
uh on SNL I think that they would
actually maybe get investigated and they
would try to figure out like what was
going on
um
I don't know I don't know what to say
here
um all right other than that I'm trying
to conserve my voice because I have
three shows this weekend I want to thank
everybody out in the great state of
Florida everybody's going to be in a
good mood
your boy's coming back
huh orange Jesus
with the greatest comb over
since mayor white in Boston
he had a great comb over in my lifetime
it was where it was supposed to be and
by the end of his mayoral run or his
tenure as mayor it was like literally
like
um
just above his ear
and he was just combing all of it over
the top of his head it looked [ __ ]
horrendous
I always wondered what that looked like
in the shower
when you had a hairdo like that like one
side of your body your head
it's like your hair is above your ear
and then on the other side you look you
look like half of Ben Franklin
you know
it's like you know what if Ben Franklin
and Tim Conway had a baby
um
God bless the wife that just [ __ ]
hangs in there with that I mean that's
just [ __ ]
I saw a guy with a full head of hair the
other day you do that a lot as a bald
guy like you look at somebody around
your age like oh look at that son of a
[ __ ]
God loves him
um and I was looking at this guy and he
but he had a haircut that made it look
like he was wearing a toupee
he had like this newscaster level local
newscaster still [ __ ] crushing it at
the Applebee's hair right and he had it
combed back but then for whatever reason
the the front of it
he had it brushed down into bangs just
like maybe like an eighth of an inch and
then cut straight across
so he gave himself like he had it lined
up
you know
like how the black guys do it you know
but he was like he wasn't a white guy I
don't know what he was
but it made it look like
that's what his hair was and then it was
bald behind it and they just set this
[ __ ]
you know cowlick [ __ ] behind it
I was actually kind of fascinating there
was a moment where I was like if I don't
stop looking at this I'm going to get
into a fight
so I just took my cup of coffee and I
walked out I mean that's how I that's
how you do it
as an old dad with two bad shoulders you
know when you feel the confrontation
coming
you know you just you just walk away
with your coffee that's just how it goes
and there's not even a moments
shame you know that's how old you are
you just walk away and you're glad
you're still your pancreas is intact
you're not going to lose your spleen and
you don't have to get all new [ __ ]
teeth
be so because some guy with a cowlick
and bangs
stomped your face in
while a bunch of [ __ ]
Barista with fisherman hats watched I
don't understand why if you make coffee
you have to wear a knitted hat like
you're about to have a snowball fight
regardless of the environment oh Bill
are you doing Coffee House material now
I think I am
you know
I think this might be part of my chunk
this weekend when I go to Jacksonville
Orlando Florida and I don't know where I
am going
I don't know where I'm going
clear water
murky Water Gator water I have no idea
where I'm going but you know what there
is some college football
I wonder what's going to happen what do
you guys think about [ __ ] Michigan
Ohio State coming up is Michigan going
to go into the Horseshoe that's not
really a horseshoe anymore
they're going to go in there and kick
them in the dick can you imagine two
years in a row
those loudmouth fans just [ __ ] eating
it oh my God at the Ohio State
University
the team that always seems to make the
playoffs and get their [ __ ] asses
kicked every [ __ ] time with the most
boring goddamn playoff game ever I'm
just [ __ ] with you you win once every
10 years
um all right that's it I think I've been
a [ __ ] enough uh God bless you go [ __ ]
yourselves enjoy the next uh
enjoy your weekend enjoy the music
picked out by the great Andrew females
um and uh then we have a bonus episode
of another episode of Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast
from a Thursday
previous to this one all right that's it
I'll see you
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it is uh time for a special edition of
the Monday Morning podcast you know
every once in a while
um old freckles here goes out and gets
himself a guest and uh today is no
different which is why we have a special
podcast for this weekend I can't think
of uh this is probably the biggest it's
got to be the biggest guest I've had an
absolute Legend and usually when people
say this [ __ ] they they can't you know
people you can't follow it but believe
it or not I have uh from Aerosmith
legendary lead guitarist Joe Perry on
the Monday morning podcast how are you
buddy I'm really good thanks uh I don't
know about the biggest part I mean most
people say you look bigger in I mean you
look smaller in person but uh don't you
hate that that don't matter I mean you
know it's all it's all about the camera
angle and all that stuff but uh thanks I
appreciate that that intro and uh do you
get that I'd like to be here today oh
sorry did you get that a lot people say
that to me like I don't know know why
they think I was tall I'm average height
I'm just under 5 10 and then they always
come walking up they're like I thought
you'd be a lot bigger it's just it's the
way that the camera because usually a
camera again technically I mean the
camera's kind of down at eye level
because I want to get you straight on
right and or sometimes they'll shoot you
from a little below so it's really hard
to tell
um to get any kind of perspective you
know what I mean unless you know how
tall the person is you're standing next
to that kind of thing
um I get it with you it's like you're
playing like you know the LA Coliseum
and you're on like a 40-foot stage I
mean I'm standing in some Chuckle Hut
it's just like I'm maybe six inches
taller than I am when I'm not on stage
so
um I don't know that's always like
sometimes I just think people just say
[ __ ] to say [ __ ] like do you how do you
deal with like you know what like amazes
me about before but before we get going
here uh the reason why Joe Perry's here
he's got a new unbelievable book uh Joe
Berry Joe Perry my life in and out of
Aerosmith that's available now in a form
of
um I'm not mistaken it already went
number one correct well I think it was
number two it was on the it's in the top
ten uh wasn't the top ten uh uh New York
Times best solo list uh it was in the
top ten for two weeks and this is why
your career has lasted for so long
because you're dishonest most people
would have just been like yeah man yeah
number one all over the place but it's
it's like anybody that that uh you know
sees it they but the thing is it's it
all they say is top top seller and they
print that on the top and that's kind of
like the stamp that says that at least
more than one person has read it and uh
and the other thing is I'm not here just
because of the book I'm here because
you're you're a Bud from way back and
I've been looking forward to doing a
podcast with you anyway oh that's
awesome for a while so it's uh yeah it
gives me a chance to yak about the book
but I also get a chance to have some
laughs for a change good deal and I
promise I'm going to try to steer away
from the usual
you know so what's Stephen like what's
uh how do you pick out your leather
pants or whatever I might ask you that
one because I don't ask me anything you
want and and I guarantee the the answers
will be totally different than they've
been from from before because
a lot of it it's not so much the
questions it's how they're asked and
who's asking them oh okay all right I
like that well let me here's one for you
is what blows my mind nowadays with the
whole Twitter thing and Facebook and the
whole interactive thing was back in the
day
um there was no way for me to ever write
you something that you would ever I
guess fan mail or something like that
just the level of like interaction that
people can have in fact like when I when
I bought your first albums it was like
uh maybe 80 81 or something like that so
this was just before MTV right I didn't
even know who was who because I turn
over the album sure like I said Greatest
Hits first and they didn't have a
picture you guys but uh when I got like
Toys in the Attic or something remember
I turned it over and I was trying to
figure out which one Steve which one's
Joe you know who's Tommy and all that
type of stuff
um how have you felt like having lived
the old way
but like pretty even like pre-m TV where
people didn't you know for them let's
say well hardcore fans they had no idea
what you look like so you could be a
little more Anonymous if you walk down
the street to like this whole thing now
where people can be like uh nice book
[ __ ] why'd you pick this picture you
know he's sitting there eating toast in
your [ __ ] kitchen
that doesn't annoy the [ __ ] I hate the
[ __ ] heckles when I'm at home well
it's it's interesting because you got
one thing is you got to keep in mind
that it's a very small percentage of the
people that are out there so you you
know a lot of times you can get like
sucked into the whole Twitter thing or
Facebook or all that stuff all the
different different Outlets that there
are and you can go God I can't believe
that people think that or or how could
they say that it's like you got to
remember that it's like maybe one of one
percent that are actually like you know
looking at it but uh
you know but it's kind of like uh
uh it's a good thing and a bad thing it
gives people a voice and you it's kind
of like the like we've said before the
uh it's like the Town Square and you're
hanging out in the town square and
anybody can say what they want some
people want to stand in a soap box so
they can be heard and very often they
get carried away in a white uh in a
white uh jacket but uh uh so you know
how long did it take for you to get to
this Zen place because it's something
that I kind of bad like most times are
like all right whatever hey you know
whatever the last eight what good what
are they all going to be good but like
just every once in a while somebody just
writes something so mean that I get like
an urge to like I just wish there was an
app where you could find out where they
lived yeah and just drive over and uh
you know it's funny I'd drive over and
then lose a fight to them but you know
in my fantasy I win yeah well uh
sometimes you have to do that to let off
some steam but uh uh not actually do it
but just kind of go through the middle
process but the point is is that uh uh
you read some of that stuff and it can
be so mean spirited because they know
that they're Anonymous and it's like
kind of a drag but uh I don't know
lately it's been uh uh pretty positive
okay you know oh that's cool it's been
kind of even and uh you know you just
kind of pay attention to to the
different ones I mean some people will
only listen to like one particular thing
or they'll kind of uh you know drop into
at different phases and things like that
so I don't know it's just just another
Outlet uh
but uh but sometimes we we do use it for
uh input when we're talking about a set
list you know we're on the road we're
thinking about you know what should we
put in there and sometimes somebody will
will tweet a song We'll go I think we
remember how to play that one we'll
throw it in the second can I can I put
out a request of course one that I've
always wanted to see play Live it's off
your first album uh moving out well let
me write that down because uh that's one
song that we do play once in a while do
you play that one played it uh I think
the second the last show of the tour and
we went right into walking the dog so it
was kind of like you know I think your
first album is so underrated because
that if I remember correctly you
basically uh you guys even after you
sold that album you hadn't gone National
yet and it was kind of like um you kind
of got like New Hampshire Vermont Maine
Massachusetts sort of New England and
maybe just into Connecticut New York
um exactly and it was just it was really
like uh it was an uphill fight Ma you
know I mean it was uh you know people
think you know if looking from the
outside you know they're looking at the
at the trade magazines and then all of a
sudden there's there's a band on the
charts and it seems like they're
overnight but you know you you forget I
mean it goes it's been it's been the
same ever since the Beatles I mean the
Beatles spent years and years in those
clubs in Hamburg sleeping in the
bathroom working hot and busting their
ass and the same thing with with us I
mean we worked the clubs and it kind of
spread out it would you know would go
through through uh Ohio and play you
know all all the towns in Ohio right and
uh and then making our way to Detroit
and Detroit of course
their favorite bed was J Giles so they
were willing to give another band from
Boston and listen and give us a second
chance you know and uh when we went out
there they they really uh took us to
heart and then uh coming back to Boston
the uh the first album uh was uh had
come and kind of gone but uh the record
company gave us another chance and we
did the second record and then they
re-release Streamwood and it started to
get played on the radio that was back
when DJs could actually play what they
wanted I know I know that'd be crazy now
you know you could actually go up there
and and talk to them play them something
if it was any good they would play it
you know it was pretty cool that's
amazing you know what I was just back uh
back East doing Dennis and Cam's uh
Comics come home yeah and believe it or
not it was the 20th the 20th anniversary
of that show and I remember one of the
times I did it you came out and played
with the band which was awesome and um
I'll tell you one thing that strikes me
is every time I go back to Boston
because I moved away in 95 it becomes
less and less like what I left and I'm
gonna be oh I'm gonna get a greasy slice
of pizza here and then it's gone and I'm
just I'm fighting it all these areas
that used to be scary are getting like
nicer and nicer and I remember you what
always kills me was when they talk about
when you guys were struggling they're
like yeah we were all struggling we were
all living in this beat up apartment on
Commonwealth Avenue which is like Park
Avenue now uh in in uh in downtown
Boston and I was wondering do you do you
miss like when you go back go through
Boston I don't know how often you get to
go back there do you um
do you like the direction it went with
the whole big dig and well turning
Southie into like a bunch of condos and
crap certainly The Big Dig was a uh was
an event in everyone's life who lives in
Boston but uh I mean it was there's no
doubt and you know why did they just
make one [ __ ] Lane they turned
everything it was like
it was a complete waste of time oh and
other than aesthetically I'm [ __ ] you
know I was driving to the airport as I
went to the airport you know I tried to
take the Ted Williams Title so I get off
I have a 7 A.M flight it's like quarter
to five in the morning and so I get off
the Ted Williams
um exit and then I get to the fork in
the row we make a left to do it and
there's all these [ __ ] cones set up
so then I have to go buy that and the
Catalan tunnel flipping the [ __ ] out
curse in Boston up and down for the the
[ __ ] State worker Meathead and I
didn't think that they they did it by
accident I literally think that they do
it on purpose and then you [ __ ] go
through all of the [ __ ] and once
again it's one lane to get to the
airport so it was like what was the
purpose of all of that you know it's
like
go figure I mean there's there's it's
all about progress under the name of
progress I mean that's what this whole
country's built on and and growth and
all that and I mean I think that things
have to change there I don't want I
don't want to get into that right now
but but the bottom line is uh are you
gonna run for office I just I haven't
been home
that much I've been out here you know
from the time we were working on the uh
the the last Aerosmith record and then
going on the road and then coming back
and finishing the record and then going
on the road again and then working on
the book all through that we've been
spending all my time here and uh uh I
know you sound like you caught a cold a
little bit and well the allergies here
it's like it's really wet you know it's
back here he's got uh it's beautiful I
mean he's got like fountains everywhere
and uh it's just beautiful but um but
the allergies get you and I was just
reading uh an article in one of the like
The Huffington Post and one of those one
of those things and they were saying how
that that people's uh
people's allergies are not allergies but
their their whole nasal thing was was
like starting to like react to the a lot
of the differences because they traveled
so much and and there are so many
different uh things that affect people
and so they're they're no if they if
you're wondering why your nose is
dripping it's why because your nose is
working overtime it's got nothing to do
with uh anything from the border you
know or anything like that it's just
strictly your body reacting to uh to the
uh to the different stuff in the air
whether it's pollen I mean I know in
Massachusetts there's that time of the
year where all the the pine pollen comes
down and it covers your car green and
all that you get sick then too uh I'll
get like it's objective that's good it's
kind of driving nuts it's terrible it's
it's like uh how do you handle that if
you have like a show if you're doing a
Joe Perry thing uh Joe Perry project
where you have to sing well I have to
use a little bit of that spray you know
that uh you know that you get it are at
the drugstore and it works as long as
you don't use too much of it you know
but it works and it's uh and uh when you
get through it that [ __ ] never works for
me somebody gave me that the other day
I'm doing a cartoon
um oh we got to get y'all uh like we
have music and stuff in between your
projects yeah we're kind of doing this
thing it takes place in like the 70s I
can't give too much of a way it's not
coming out for like another year but uh
you know what what we're
we're doing some stuff uh period
stuff from the 70s like you remember
when plant and Page used to do that
column response thing on the guitar
so we kind of got some people listening
to music like that and um
I as I was driving over here today I was
like Jesus Christ you know I mean I
should have got you in on the [ __ ]
thing we're having somebody uh try to
put together like a song for us or
whatever but uh I'd love to have you
come in maybe even do a voice or
something like that at some point that's
one of the good things about uh about
all this technology is you don't have to
be in the same room at the same time you
know I mean certainly there's a
advantage to that but you know if if you
can't be there physically you can
certainly you know send the files and
you can work on it and talk on the phone
I mean I just did a
um an over an overdub on one of Johnny
Winter's songs uh
God Rest his soul
and uh you know he called me up and said
you want to play on the wreck and he
said yeah great and uh they sent me the
files and they said I played on it and
uh like right yeah well Jesus here
there's a studio right next door so uh
we went in well as you noticed I'm not
too good with technology I got to tell
my listeners the embarrassing
be getting to my podcast I was in a rush
to get over here I'm freaking out Joe
Perry from Aerosmith then I show up I
got two microphones I got everything but
I only have one mic cord and rock star
Joe Perry goes I'll go next door and get
one like he's getting no like he has all
cool neighbors so like he's right like
I'd go over and get a cup of sugar he
goes over and gets a microphone cord
well you know I would stand to reason to
hang around with people with kind of
musical people but also that we stay at
the hotel the sunset Marquis I don't
know where you stand but they have a
studio downstairs and that's the only
Hotel I know of in the world where you
can call room service and get a
microphone at two in the morning is that
right if you're like uh I mean I've done
a lot of uh of writing in fact there's a
picture of me uh in in the in the room
uh working on one of the songs for the
record and uh you know and we just set
up with the with the computer and the
some some outboard gears some
microphones and uh we'll be sitting
there and and I actually wrote the song
there and some of the tracks actually
made it on the record but you know we're
just sitting in the living room you know
and it's uh and I needed a mic cord and
I called down and they had it there and
it was do you find that that new
technology makes you uh more creative or
is it like you know sometimes there's
people out here where even if they they
like right they're sitting there going
like well I gotta at least have an
office where I go to sit down and write
because if I don't I'm sitting here the
TV's here the kitchen's here I'm not
going to create do you find uh the new
technology wherever you go there's a
studio makes you procrastinate more or
do you work work more it's definitely a
lot more uh a lot it takes a lot more uh
get up and go to to do it because there
are so many more distractions there's no
doubt about it everything from you know
a thousand channels on TV to to whatever
you're into I mean football in 24 hours
a day I mean whatever there's so many
things that you know it's an advantage
because you can you can choose but on
the other hand it's like uh to be able
to record in your own house can be like
the worst thing and the best thing I
mean
you can always say well I can put it off
till tomorrow right because you don't
you know you haven't booked time in a
studio where they're going to charge you
fifteen hundred dollars a day whereas
you've already put a deposit down on a
studio right so you have to go so this
is kind of like uh there's that end of
it and then there's also but it really
has to come from from inside and you
have to really want to do it and uh I
mean you know you're you're I mean
you're a creative guy you see things I
wouldn't go that far in a different way
than most people I wouldn't go that far
and you see you see the the humor and
stuff uh and you know stuff that we
would never occur the rest of us but
that's why you make us laugh and the
thing is it's that's that's an art and
let me ask you this you said that that
Sunset Marquis the only hotel that you
know that you can order a microphone uh
what's the craziest thing you ever
ordered room service
you're on the road you're in the middle
of nowhere it wasn't so much the
craziest thing it was the quantity
are we talking grams here
what did you order well enough for say
30 people uh
what is uh Dom Perignon uh uh by the
case uh I was I could rub a stand at the
uh at the Beverly Hills Hotel in the 70s
and it was kind of like the uh party
central because they have Bungalows out
back you know like geez it's the 70s and
everything can be cured as far as STDs
go and all that I mean do you ever
missed like I I look at some of the 70s
right yeah and I just really wish I mean
of course it's all been romanticized in
books and movies and all that [ __ ] but
do you like aside everybody likes being
younger do you miss those days like
thinking about like just how a lot Freer
and crazy you could be without worrying
about somebody with a cell phone camera
I'm talking about single Joe Perry
I got this drinking and drugging thing
under control like you just you're just
having a good time you're playing with
your band you're selling records and all
that is a part of you that you ever just
yeah but like when you're driving down
sunset and just looking at spots going
like dude I I [ __ ] bought a kilo of
coke there and I had one of the best hot
dogs I ever had in my life hanging with
John Bonham or something dude like do
you do the memories like that still come
yeah I mean there's no doubt I mean
especially here in in L.A and there are
a couple of places that are still you
know the same buildings some of them
changed the names but I mean this is
whiskey a go-go and there's Book Soup
which has been there forever which is
greatest bookstores going next to uh
city lights up in Frisco and there's one
in Paris that's really good but but you
know there are these certain places that
are still there and you know the rainbow
and and the Roxy and uh who are some of
the people you remember seeing in the
rain just because fans are like like me
who are like nerds it's like you just
want to you just want to go to the same
place that they stood in chances are if
if they if if they were playing in town
uh you could almost guaranteed to be to
see whoever was playing and then the
rest of the time you know a lot of
people would just if they were in the
middle of a tour they had a couple days
off they would definitely come to LA to
hang out because it's such a great scene
here for you know back then and uh you
could literally like run into anybody
what's the craziest thing you ever saw
go down at like the rainbow room or the
whiskey or whatever like the most well I
I only hung out there a few times uh
because you don't have to name anything
I'm not trying to get you in trouble
with anyone but uh I just uh
it was just uh a couple of times I've
been there you know I mean actually
probably a lot more than I remember but
uh that's probably a lot more than that
than I would forget maybe you're the
central person in the story you just
don't remember the story what's
happening about Joe Perry but uh you
know it was basically a kind of a
meeting place for everybody that would
come down from the hills you know run
into whoever and then the tables would
empty out and as people would take off
and it was that kind of a place but uh
uh I I haven't been up there you know
since uh Jesus in in forever so uh well
I can guarantee you I don't think
they've changed anything when you walk
in there all of the the covers on the
seat and everything just look like
they've been there since the beginning
of time I would bet I would bet uh and
the whiskey is pretty much the same as I
remember when we played there our first
time here in LA and then we played there
you know not too long ago and it was
pretty much the same it was a great Vibe
you know so it's kind of like uh
the paradise I don't even know have they
changed the paradise at all in Boston
yeah dude the paradise has been going
for I think almost 20 years well I guess
they've changed with that
but uh it's probably like is it a club
still or is it a no you know the deal is
probably one of those [ __ ] Panera
Bread yeah things and you're just
thinking yeah you too and the police
started here or there for some of their
first gigs I guess in the United States
were here you know I just realized as
I'm sitting in here um You probably I
can't imagine them I think the amount of
times you've sat in a room where there
was just a suit of armor over in the
corner yeah like some Scooby-Doo [ __ ]
this seems like some real like rock star
stuff like you gotta have you just gotta
have a suit of armor near you right that
helps your creative process it came with
the place oh it did you know but oddly
oddly enough I did have one in my house
in uh
in the 70s I had a I had a pseudo armor
at the door and uh where do you where do
you buy that well don't you have to buy
a castle it's not a real one obviously I
mean it's not not like a like one that
uh I mean you can tell it's it's just
it's like a mock-up of one but it still
looks really cool and uh how do you know
it's not real because there's no because
Mark's on it if you look at this it
where the screws hold it that hold it
together they kind of like didn't cut
off the edge so if you were to put it on
you'd kind of look like uh you just got
attacked by about a about a hundred uh
oh yeah mosquitoes or wasps or whatever
because uh all those little those Nails
would be sticking in you if you took the
helmet off you'd see like like the
rivets sticking out so it's really not
made to oh I just looked at it and I
didn't see any scuff marks on it I just
figured that was like the King's son you
know who never had to go to battle but
yeah parade down the street good
observation because it's probably true
but I I mean it's probably copy feet off
of uh off of a real one but there are
places you can get things like that uh
you see an odd one and uh you know odd
piece in the in the quarter or some some
uh you know uh home and garden place or
whatever and you know
I guess that's uh where they come from
you know but hey I saw you guys at Jones
Beach in like uh 2006 you have awesome
awesome show as always and
um Motley Crew was opening for you guys
on that tour and they're uh recently
there there I think this is going to be
their their final tour and all that do
you remember the um because I'm a huge
you know being a drummer geek I'm a huge
fan of Tommy Lee he was uh yeah just
like you know just the the show that
that guy puts on while also playing a
beat is just amazing I've always loved
him and uh I was one do you remember the
first time you guys uh did you tour with
them during their their when they were
just young guys coming up I actually I
saw them at one of their first gigs uh
at the uh Santa Monica Civic Center when
I was with the project I was out here
um doing some gigs and uh just for the
fans was this the first the first time
Stephen left during that period was this
like early because no no this was this
is when I left in 1979 and I had the I
was out here with the project uh
at some point I'm not exactly sure when
uh but the bottom line is is I got to
see them play you know at the at the uh
Santa Monica Civic Center which is I
don't know three to five thousand seats
and the buzz was out on him so the place
was pretty packed and uh is that what
got you there you just you just heard a
good Buzz about him you're like I'm
gonna go check these guys out yeah and
uh they said well somebody said these
These are the the this is the new hot
band on on the strip and you should
check them out and so I went down and
um I'm not sure if I if I met him then
but there were uh we had a couple of
friends in common and I remember meeting
uh uh
Nikki Sixx and uh and just kind of like
you know being kind of friends with them
you know from just kind of watching that
career and then then uh we were in
Vancouver doing I think it was uh uh the
second record not not uh not prudent
vacation but I think it was the next one
uh uh pump I think and uh and there are
two studios in that in that place Little
Mountain up there in Vancouver and they
were in the other studio and so we ran
into each other a lot oh wow so they
were probably doing uh Dr Feelgood right
around then if that was 89.90 right
that's right they were uh with uh uh
let's see uh
uh Mr Rock the uh the producer was uh uh
producing their record I think and uh
Bobby Rock right uh yeah that's it and
he was and they were they was they
sounded great and uh uh they it was you
know we ran into them pretty much daily
and they uh and of course some of the
guys you know would uh they would attack
after after the session they would tag
along and go down to the to the clubs
you know Vancouver reputably
is it probably has the best
from what I've heard has some of the
best strip clubs you gave them a ride
right you're like yeah headliner I'll
give you youngsters a ride down there
they they do everybody by the first name
by the time was that hard to be around
guys like that because I know by then
you'd long since cleaned up and
everything had you you had your fun
basically at that point not at all I
mean it was not not an issue I mean
there were uh uh they were and they you
know what they uh uh you know they would
party like late at night after they were
done but when they when they came into
the studio in the afternoon they were
all business just like you know that's
what I figured is that a myth as far as
people like it's not like they walked in
with a bottle of Jack Daniels like Yahoo
let's go it's like you know they had
work to do and uh you know that's it
shows because it was it was a great
record hey did you ever call anybody out
for doing the iced tea in in the uh in
the Jack Daniels bottle you know a
couple I've heard a couple bands they
would put iced tea in the Jack Daniels
bottle and then they'd go out in front
of the crowd and act like they were
crazy and they'd just be chugging iced
tea I heard about that but I've never
you never busted anybody doing it
ran into anybody that did it but I heard
stories about bands doing that but uh uh
you know of course they don't rate very
high on my respect list but you know
that'd be like a prop act with the
community drink it you might as well
drink it you know what I mean what's
what's the problem if you don't so well
I don't care how but the big giveaways I
don't give
okay how much you drink nobody can chug
hard alcohol you just can't do it you
can fit like I've seen guys take big
gulps but once you start throwing the
thing back
like Joe Greene in that famous
commercial when he's drinking Coca-Cola
and even he had a couple times on a
couple takes he had to stop and belch or
whatever there's no way he could do with
hard alcohol but before before we go any
further I wanted to ask you you got a
really cool tattoo on your forearm there
of uh the second old school gun what's
what's uh what's the story behind that
uh Smith and Wesson uh break top
Schofield uh I guess it was designed
back in the 1800s oh yeah and uh it's I
I just like the shape of it it's one of
my favorite favorite designs it's an old
revolver and uh you know it's a place in
New Orleans I I didn't had an acting gig
down there and uh somewhere in the
French Quarter they had all these old
guns and rifles you haven't been in
there I've dropped way too much money in
that place yeah I wanted to buy my dad
this this it was a rifle from like the
from 1812 right it was insane and they
even had the bayonet and everything and
my dad likes that type of [ __ ] but the
thing was
for me to get it
from Louisiana all the way up like first
of all I couldn't get it shipped because
Massachusetts has some sort of laws
right so then I'd have to would have had
to buy it and then drive it up there and
as as I was crossing state borders I
just kept thinking about Tommy Chong
when he sent the bongs out and [ __ ] and
all of a sudden he had the feds at his
door and
you know who the [ __ ] is going to drive
from New Orleans all the way to
Massachusetts and drive 55. it's not
going to be me I'm going to drive 80 at
some point be like I'm fine it's it's
tough I think that they must get hanging
out the back you know again without
getting into into the politics of things
I mean uh I just think that the uh that
things should be a little more things
should be a little more standardized as
far as Firearms go I think they should
be uh I mean people should be give it at
least uh you know
put through more uh schooling before
they're given a permit and and it should
be more standardized from state to state
because there are some states where it's
it's easier to get Firearms than there
are other states where it's really hard
and it's it is insane to to it's hard to
to keep track of it again it's insane
how in some states you can basically
just go in and buy it and not have to
prove any sort of capability I mean it'd
be like given like somebody doesn't know
how to drive keys to a car it's like
they're gonna kill somebody
um but I I honestly I don't have uh a
problem with guns I think they're cool
as long as the right person owns it
which is the big of course fly in the
ointment but uh what are some of your
you liked uh the gun you just mentioned
there what are some of your uh
your go-to guns like right some of the
modern stuff what do you like well uh
I'm not really a
I mean I I have a few more modern uh uh
Firearms I collect all kinds of weapons
I've even got a an old Greek sword uh
that's uh made out of bronze it's all
like it's green and it's it's actually
quite small
like seems a little smaller but anyway
uh uh if somebody broke into your house
you can't tell me if they're coming up
the stairs right and the only weapon you
see is that old Greek sword party's got
to be like ah God that cost me a fortune
well do I really want to run this guy
through with it what they what they're
going to be doing is focusing on that
while I walk behind them with my shotgun
oh yeah you're a shotgun inside guy well
I do have uh you know I mean it they're
reliable they're uh and uh but what
about what about like understand as uh
you uh if you're in that situation uh
there's a level of panic that comes with
it and I've never been in that situation
before fortunately and uh I hope it
stays that way but uh you know I'm not
I've never been in the Army I've never
been trained and uh you know uh so I
kind of look at things like the easiest
thing that would be to have you know
around for for if somebody got that far
you know would be something that would
be very easy to use and shotgun comes
into that heading so uh but again it's
like uh it's an efficiency thing I've
always you know because I've actually
you know toured through the South that I
always tell them they're out of their
minds to have a shotgun in their house I
got a whole bit coming out of my next
special about it where I always think
all you need is like a 22.
um because it's easy my big thing is you
can you're when you're in the dock if
you shoot you can still hear it doesn't
you've already lost your sight it's not
going to take away your hearing too and
people always laugh at a 22 but it's
like dude if I had it loaded 22 and I
pointed it at you you're diving you're
running away and if I started shooting
you with it you wouldn't be laughing
going this is a 22. I could shoot you
with a BB gun you're gonna be like I'm
gonna get the [ __ ] out of here people
people you know it also it's kind of
hard to tell you know what it is you
have in your head the whole thing is
it's so much there's so much psychology
that goes along with it and I've studied
a lot of that because uh uh again you
know if you've got to have it's a great
responsibility to own firearms and I've
done a lot of of uh of studying I've
worked with people I haven't actually
gone to any any of the uh the places
where you can go to train but I've
talked to a lot of of instructors and so
on and uh and uh from what I gathered I
handguns are probably the least
effective and even in the hands of of
trained Imaging people people Miss I
think that uh Hemingway said that of all
of all the weapons out there
the weapon that misses the most is a
handgun because there's so much moving
and so much going on and it's I would
think just the sound alone I'm hearing a
gun I'm not going to be sitting there if
I'm breaking your house counting shots
like they do in the movie and that'll be
at the bottom going Joe I know you're
out of bullets yeah come out with you I
mean I'm not gonna fight the second
somebody starts shooting at me I'm
thinking I'm gonna go rob another house
I would just think people would do that
but well I I don't know you know what I
did see you on that show was it son of a
gun yeah Sons of Guns Sons of Guns man
that must have been fun as hell for
people who don't know I don't even know
if it's still on there's so many
freaking channels and shows but these
guys just it was like a hot rod show
except it was guns and these guys would
just make these insane
weapons uh and then people got to come
on the show you know they'd weld like
m60s to like the top of a Prius or
something like that right right
what did uh what did you get to shoot on
that like some anti-aircraft guns they
had a couple of uh of uh uh hot rodded
so to speak uh you know like uh M16s and
things like that so we shot those but
the main thing was I had this uh this
old kid that was uh actually from the
1800s and uh I really didn't know much
about it and they they kind of uh
cleaned it up a little bit and got into
the serial number and it was actually a
military issue and it was actually a
naval gun and when two ships are at Sea
and they want to transport like a cargo
or a person or something back and forth
they need to send the line from one ship
to the other so they used this kid and
which is it's only about three feet long
and they shoot this this uh this lead
Dart over to the other boat and it it
takes a rope with it then they put they
attach a bigger rope to it then a bigger
rope and a bigger rope and and then
finally they have this pulley thing so
they can transport stuff back and forth
so that's what that's what it was for
how many people who think accidentally
got killed on the other ship you know
when even though that they knew that
they were shooting it over it was just
such not an exact science it didn't
really take wind you know you kind of
wet your finger back then right I have
no feeling that people would probably
keep their heads up watching where the
thing was going I mean I'm sure but you
go to a baseball game somebody gets
dinged in the head all the time they're
just [ __ ] sitting there and these
guys are like trying to hit 190 100 mile
an hour pitches and there's always
somebody just sitting there eating and
talking and they get they always get hit
in the chest thank God like a few people
actually gotten hit in the head but I
got to ask you there's something about
cannons that I realized as I was talking
to you my only knowledge of canons is
what I've seen in cartoons I'm not even
trying to be funny here and there's
there's they try to make it look like
you know the thing that they stick in
there is like a little bomb and then
they shoot it and explodes but it's
really it's just a giant like uh ball
made out a metal and that gets launched
through gunpowder right so this giant
metal ball that pokes a hole in your
ship and sinks it well so
from what I understand because I've read
quite a few uh uh historic novels and
and that part of that part of History uh
fascinates me you know the the tall
ships and all that and apparently some
of the some of the the things they would
put in there would actually be filled
with gunpowder with a with a fuse so
when it would when it would get shot off
it would you know it was very inaccurate
and uh you know once in a while it would
work but it would it would uh you know
it would land on the ship and it
hopefully explode but whatever well that
goes back to the dart I'm saying it's
very inaccurate they'd shoot yeah and
they probably somebody caught it in the
leg right and then they got a sawed off
they just give them some whiskey yeah
right I'll tell you uh medicine was not
anything near what we think you know
think of Medicine well you know up till
up to the end of the night of the 18th
century it was like just basically that
you know if you got a hangnail foot
comes in a is coming off or uh you know
how to do that thing just just to stitch
you up they just stick your leg in a
fire yeah quick easy cheap you know so
isn't it amazing like the amount of pain
that you can actually take do you know I
saw this this thing as far as like
horrific horrific ways to die they had
this thing okay you did something they
decided that you were gonna die and they
had this giant like it was like a
[ __ ] brass cow or some sort of animal
it made out of some sort of metal right
right and they would stick you in the
[ __ ] thing how they ever got you in
because I would have just killed myself
they stick in the [ __ ] thing they
close it up and then they light a fire
underneath it and they would just
basically cook you
I've always thought about that laying in
there as it's getting hot bouncing all
around like someone who [ __ ] fell off
a motorcycle trying not to have the heat
on you for too long right it's just the
the [ __ ] Agony and how these people
could just sit there and uh who said
who's that guy who used to uh they'd
they'd put you on a uh what the [ __ ] do
they call the Impaler oh yeah Vlad the
the Dracula they called us I love how
you said that like you knew him oh yeah
I mean I've read read that stuff you
know we've all read it we've seen it in
movies and you know he's uh I actually
watched a video and there you know to me
what it means to me is the way that
people have invented to [ __ ] other
people up over the years it just blows
my mind what's the worst one you ever
heard oh god well that was pretty close
I mean that that really like that and I
can't imagine being uh I mean I love
horses but I can't imagine being tied to
four of them oh you know what I mean and
then having somebody yell and go okay
pull a little harder not not even like
you know get up you know get up and go
and like making it short but like
actually just kind of like oh they
wouldn't they slowly had him walk apart
I mean that kind of thing that's that
sounds like a pretty rotten way to go
those people listen at home would don't
you basically they would tie you know
your wrist to one horse you know your
wrist to another your ankle to one and
they would walk in four different
directions and then they'd slowly
[ __ ] dislocate your joints and then
eventually just yeah pull you apart and
that's yeah I want to say one thing I do
want to say going back to we were
talking about before which was uh about
you know home and home defense and all
that but one of the things that I've
I've learned from talking to
umpteen people about this and that is
that a dog any size dog is probably the
most effective
thing you could have in your house
for safety just because the main thing
is is getting some enough time to either
deal with what to deal with what you
have to deal with make make the 9-1-1
call you know jump out the window if
that's what has to happen pull out
whatever your your last ditch uh weapon
of choices but the main thing is buying
some time and a dog will basically send
the guy off to somebody else's house and
then it's their problem I got a dog my
dog will do that like every once in a
while I'll be sleeping and I I get so
terrified I'll just sleeping all of a
sudden dog just starts going
yeah man I sit there going like what and
I sit
I'm such a coward and I'm immediately
like and then I'm thinking like I should
have got a gun I should have bought a
gun you know I wish I had a bat here or
something well I got it that's a good
thing yeah I have a knife this cop told
me a knife is stupid because you got to
get in close so at least have a bat yeah
um but the dog and again a dog a small
dog any dog that's you know becomes part
of the family he's going to protect the
pack and he's going to let somebody know
and uh that that really they on all the
lists I've ever seen they've put they're
like in the top three things you could
you could have that could be the the
best thing and uh anyway
so we've got to whine down here because
I gotta another freaking thing I gotta
run through once again sorry that I
didn't have a x to my chord no that's
okay pretty unprofessional man hey I
didn't even imagine you went over there
twice because the other thing you first
one you brought didn't fit my stupid
mixer it's yeah it actually goes to a
little to an old microphone that uh like
an old an old sour one that needs power
so it had two two more extra prongs and
it didn't work the reality is I showed
up uh unprepared but I got let me ask
you can I ask you some uh uh music geek
questions here sure okay uh so whatever
you want man all right the the best live
band other than your own band best live
band you ever saw
well they have to say uh
my theory is is that uh
of rock and roll show if we're talking
about rock and roll rock and roll the
interaction interaction between the feds
and the band and
a lot of times you might be in a club
and it might not even be a big band but
they they've got good songs and they're
they're getting the audience off and the
audience has given them love and the
band is giving it back and you get that
feeling like wow this is Magic and right
then they might be the best band right
you know uh that night they're the best
band and you know you you walk away and
you feel great and it was like an
incredible show so that's kind of like
what we strive for is that what we try
and do that try and get that magic going
and that that's the thing you can't you
can line everything up make sure the
guitars are in tune make sure everything
was working but it's really about you
know hooking up with the audience and
and having that that interaction and
having that excitement and uh I have to
say that that one of the shows uh that
that I've seen recently was actually
Stones I mean and it sounds like you
know yeah of course pick the stones but
it was I've seen him on nights when they
just weren't that good you know I've
seen them when they were really good
back back in uh the 60s and uh but this
particular night we were on the road in
Germany and they played a place in
Berlin and they sounded incredible and
it was like
it was one of those nights where they
where everything just locked together
and you could see you know 50 years of
experience you could hear everything it
was a it was a perfect a perfect venue
it only held about 5 000 people and
I was blown away I mean I you know I
mean I figured it would be like you know
well there you know it would be like wow
they're really good for 70. no they were
as good as any band I'd ever seen and
they were as good as any of the the
great shows I saw in the in in in the
day and they were they they knocked me
out man I have to say you know anybody
any young players out there uh it's
crazy now trying to figure out who the
guys are because there's no centralized
area for music anymore but are there any
young players out there that you watch
and play and they inspire you like man I
gotta go home and practice or I wanna I
wanna try to take my you know like just
as a comedian to try to relate it like
you know I love new comics and I like
seeing somebody there's nothing I love
more than seeing a young comic that I
know is going to be great right and um
and you see and they got the hunger they
got the drive they got the talent and
you know that they're gonna you just
know you know they're gonna do it I
always that always gives me like a jolt
of energy because I remember what that
was like uh being their age and stuff
and like how it you know just sort of
trying to recapture like you know
because sometimes you can get into the
grind of it I was wondering if there was
any like bands that are out right now
that that make you like [ __ ] man I you
know maybe you're not near your guitar
and you're just like [ __ ] I wish I had
my guitar in my hand right now I want to
just just start making music I don't
know I I hear some good some good music
I was in the studio the other day and
there was a band that was being uh they
were recording and you know the vocal
wasn't on it yet and but the music
sounded like it had like some real
potential uh it's a really hard question
because it's like there are a lot of
technically great players and there's a
few like really great players that are
really young uh they're they have uh uh
there's so much on the internet uh I
mean you can I mean back in when I was
growing up I had to find I had to
struggle to find somebody who even
played guitar much less uh you know get
a get a lesson you know you know
I [ __ ] up my foot trying to figure out
John Bonham's bass drum technique
because I was trying to do with my like
my big toe and I was like arching my
foot and I got like uh what do you call
it that plantar fasciitis really and now
it's like you can go because all I had
was like a record player and speakers
and you stick and you you slow it down
and now like I just go on YouTube and
somebody just shows you yeah yeah it's
like a slide step you just kind of move
your whole foot and it's like you know
your leg goes up once but you get two
hits and it's just and then I'm watching
like some [ __ ] kid like eight years
old
playing all that stuff and I'm just like
it's they can get like a Year's worth of
drum lessons or guitar lessons in in one
night on YouTube that's not exactly it
and you know I mean that it's all
spelled out and that's why I think there
are a lot of a lot of good guitar
players out there that are technically
good they can play the play all the
stuff but still it still comes down to
writing a good song writing something
that that you know is a little bit
original and you know and and it's
entertaining and it still comes down to
that you can be a you can be a wizard on
guitar but unless you're a guitar freak
you know as far as like you know
entertaining
your average Rock fan you still got to
write write a good song you got to
connect it you know what I mean it's and
no matter you know whether it's like you
know you got 6 000 computers and you've
got you know it's running through tape
machines and all you know like you got
all the best equipment unless you got a
good song you still got nothing so that
will never change and uh let me ask you
because I gotta I gotta wrap up here as
far as your book that's out uh first of
all where where can fans get it I know
it's on Amazon if there's any local
bookstores well there's a few actually
there's there's a lot more than I
expected I I mean I went through
probably six or seven cities and uh most
of them we went to uh I think we only we
did a couple of Barnes and Noble but we
did mostly uh more mom and pop kind of
places but what I found out was most of
them do their business online and so
there's there's some competition from
Amazon you know it keeps everybody kind
of honest there's nobody's got a
monopoly you know so
but uh basically the best thing to do is
is uh either order from your local
bookstore support the the you know Mom
and Pop kind of places or you know get
it from from Amazon and right now
hopefully it should still be on the
shelves and uh I know I signed a bunch
of them so this still that's still an
opportunity to get some that have been
signed you know whatever people buy the
book uh is there a favorite story or one
that comes to mind if you've got a quick
one that you want to tell here at the
end uh is it basic is it stories about
you on the road with these guys is it is
it the whole thing like Joe it's it's an
autobiography from the time I put both
feet on the ground
from it's it's 64 years man of life well
I've been a part of that is Aerosmith
you know yeah I've been a fan of you for
so long that I know some of the story I
remember like you told some cool story
in some other interview where you
um how you ended up getting into guitar
you were a young kid and there was these
older guys sitting on the front porch
playing guitar and you're like oh it
just sounded really cool just sort of
captured your attention
um I well personally I cannot wait to
read it and I am like
fascinated with that whole period of
music that you came up in and I also
like that whole thing where you guys you
know had to stick your ear to a speaker
or try and slow it down and because I
find a lot of times when I'm you know I
mess around with guitar too and I try to
watch somebody play it then turn my back
to the video because right because and
people like the person will literally
break it down show you that where they
put their fingers and stuff and people
will still ask for tabs and I'm just
looking at like don't you ever want to
have the freedom to like basically I've
always figured becoming literate in
music means you could listen to it and
figure it out where if you always had to
have tabs and everything it was almost
like you couldn't even read you know
what I mean right someone had to hold
your hand and uh like I think this a lot
of people out there that can really play
all this [ __ ] but if you just played it
on a record can you sit down maybe you
don't need to do it anymore because
there's someone who will will break it
down for you but uh but anyways dude I'm
such a huge fan of you and your band and
all the stuff that you guys have done I
never even thanked you for all the great
music I mean it's basically a soundtrack
of my use
I love all your stuff and I'm so psyched
for this book I cannot wait to read it
once again it's called Joe Perry my life
in and out of Aerosmith uh so psyched I
finally got you here on the podcast yeah
good luck with the allergies thanks for
showing all your stories about guns and
all this other stuff I hope uh I asked
you some different questions it did it
was great and we'll have to do this
again because I was like I said I was
looking forward to it I've been looking
forward to it before the book or you
know I mean uh you know I mean it the
main reason was because we're from
Boston yeah it's great to hear the
accent it is I know I can't get rid of
it by the way do it again we'll talk
definitely Boston Civil War you know
definitely definitely all right Joe
Perry his new book my life in and out of
Aerosmith is available all over the
Internet and uh if you got a mom and pop
store down the street you want to help
them out bookstore down there please go
down and pick it up uh Joe Perry thank
you so much for uh listening to the
Monday Morning podcast hope to see you
soon okay
[Music]
foreign what's up everybody and welcome
back to the anything better podcast and
we are here for our NFL preview of week
11 coming up uh with our sponsor bet MGM
of course the best lines out there uh
last week we didn't lose a game last
week we actually uh I kind of stayed
status quo two and two did Bill Bill did
you go three and one yeah one three and
one oh Billy gained the game three oh
three and one yeah wait who was your uh
who was your loss I'm making the prevent
Defense work for me who is your loss
your own what was your [ __ ] [ __ ]
no I don't yeah you do when I went up
against you I don't know don't don't do
that Sicilian I swear to god dude fell
off the truck
I went ahead with you and you picked the
right team there you go Paul
there you go you got it
holy [ __ ] he fell off Jacksonville
Florida man
and we were down here shooting guns with
silencers
okay now we're gonna tastes like [ __ ] by
the way it does not taste like chicken
it's that alligator nugget was [ __ ]
horrible dude it made me sick and I
still remember the texture of it it was
gross it was horrible alligator is
[ __ ] terrible
now I'll get a bunch of people going
well I don't depends on how you cook it
well going into week 11 guys before we
get started we have to talk about our
great sponsor bet MGM the best lines
um up to date live lines bet MGM get
with them and here's how you do how do
you do it Bill here's how do you do it
here's how you do it all you got to do
is download the BET MGM app and then you
put a bonus code in Burr that's b-u-r-r
it's very simple and guess what they're
gonna give you guys all you got to do is
a minimum of ten dollars in the account
and you'll get up to a thousand dollars
uh in free bets even if you lose just
download the app a thousand dollars
download the I don't know dude I'm
trying to fight a cold
I'm fighting it with rested vitamins
um but just use bonus code b u r r
that's Burr bonus code Burr go They're
gonna put in you put in a minimum of 10
you get a thousand dollars
um up to a thousand dollars in free bets
so there you go uh it's easy to use the
the lines are live constantly and here
we go so we're going into a week 11. you
know why we're both sick Paul because we
got the vaccine
that's what they don't want you to know
yeah ever since I got that moderna I've
been I've been a different person I've
had cancer four times since I got five
my wife told me I'm a different man I'm
not the man she married since I got
injected I got an x-ray and they said I
have 19 microchips in me
uh uh dude I'll tell you what I did I'll
tell you what I did and then we'll get
going to these picks but you know this
because you grew up in a dentist office
dude I decided to not get one implant
but I decided to get two in the same
sitting and uh hey I gotta tell you hey
the last 70 hours haven't been great
okay
dude anybody does dentist work do one at
a time that's what I've learned it it
takes longer do one at a time you know
do the whole thing I was [ __ ] numb
for a half a day it was brutal yeah but
he gave you the option you chose it yeah
I go can I do two in a day and then he
they just go I should have known when
they go yeah I mean you can
but don't blame it the dentist always
gets blamed because you can I go okay
uh but yeah but the fact that you
destroyed your teeth and now you had to
go in there how the [ __ ] do you need two
implants at your age one one just got
something happened with one a long time
ago and the other you didn't take care
of it okay you know question floss and
then yeah
I floss I floss this tooth God I'm not
talking about how you dress Paul laughs
my floss Bill I've lost the chain now
there you go it's hilarious
um all right we're going in we're going
into week 11. I actually think okay call
me optimistic hey I'm hey that's Paul
it's nice he's Optimist holy upbeat
um I think we're starting to learn about
NFL teams now that's why you know so I
think I've seen enough I think we'll see
though
oh Andrew what about record addiction to
wanting to know
every [ __ ] week
when you're not winning you're going
like I'm not seeing it and then when you
start winning you're going like you know
what I think I'm starting to know these
times I'm not winning though I'm not
winning I think I'm starting to you know
really like
I'm 500 dude I'm not winning two and two
is not winning I'm two and two or one
and three every [ __ ] week I'm not
winning but I think Bill Parcells was
right with what he said and you know
what Bill Parcell said he said you are
what your [ __ ] record is and that's
why the [ __ ] Packers stink so that's
what I'm talking about I'm I'm trying to
have some hope here Bill I'm grasping
for straws here Andrew what are our
records
I want to give you that Dick Gregory
thing when he [ __ ] yells at that kid
when he talks about hope
oh I saw I know I posted that I can't
have oh [ __ ]
it's like all right dude stop yelling at
me
it's hoping to pay the rent is hoping to
pay the rent and [ __ ] holes I hope I
get a cup of coffee this morning
say I will get that [ __ ] [ __ ]
and you're like all right all right
quick
hey he's having a rough morning okay hey
Richard
what are our records Andrew uh bill is
18 19 and don't ask what our records are
tell us a record [ __ ] you think
hope is gonna get you to 500
uh
Bill what's Bill what's Bill 18 19 and
three oh oh that means I got my nose
there we're above 500 with the ties
you're over 500 by half a game okay but
my Alpha Game up he's beating the book
right he's beating the book he's [ __ ]
we're back he's beating the book what am
I Andrew stop eating the book the book
is [ __ ] breathing down my neck
17 22 and 1.
17 22 and one okay so I'm four and a
half games back okay
all right
all right Paul didn't like that that
song a bit I thought yeah I wanted it
isn't quite as white right now Paul Paul
you want to close up this week next week
we're gonna hear about it you wanna know
something my friend knows me well
because I wanted that number to be one
or two less it bugged me it bugged me he
knows he knows
um all right
you look like that guy who took a punch
he was trying to pretend it didn't hurt
uh okay here we go week 11 I believe
it's my pick first
I I wouldn't have touched the Packers
but I oh I was thinking about it I'm
glad we didn't do this yesterday
um
you know something
the Green Bay packing it in what I did
not like is the Jets Patriots line
Changed by half a point and it's the
perfect change so I don't I don't like
it what does it say what is it it used
to be Packers minus three at home I mean
I'm sorry it used to be it used to be
Patriots minus three now it's three and
a half and and that's a division rival
and uh
they played the Patriots the Jets played
the Patriots really good last time until
Zach Wilson floated up a couple
interceptions I think the Patriots could
win I don't like the 0.5 so I'm staying
away I was gonna touch it though
um
I must have old lines because mine's
still said three
all right
here we go dude what are we gonna do
here
all right I'm gonna oh you're on the
clock this is a crazy one dude but I'm
gonna do it man I'm gonna do it
I think the Eagles got exposed a little
bit I think there's still a really
really great team but I like the Colts
at home you [ __ ] bastards I like the
culture I put on my bets dude I'm
getting tired of it the Colts has been
my team the whole [ __ ] year I see
what you're doing no how are you gonna
take the Patriots your [ __ ] [ __ ] on
that and now you're coming oh yeah built
one last week with the [ __ ] Colts now
I'm gonna do it because I've been riding
the Raiders in the Packers copycat
League Paul I see what you're doing dude
I was complaining about the Colts when
we were in Arizona live are you kidding
me copycat League Paul I see what you're
doing
all right where the [ __ ] are my bets
here I'm just I'm gonna take I'll take
the Colts plus six and a half at home oh
will you Paul and you'll get a nice big
fat Victory you [ __ ] I don't know oh
dude you know what you're doing you're
Lance Armstrong right now you're
drafting off of my bets never dude well
I actually took the Colts 500 I'm gonna
start taking his [ __ ] team dude I
actually took the Colts the first two
weeks then I don't want to hear facts
and then nobody took the cold sore guys
I'm [ __ ] around I'm [ __ ] around
okay all right bears plus three versus
the Falcons I'll take that oh
oh
it's a good one there's a pop try to put
the [ __ ] Juju on my [ __ ] thing oh
all right here we go
was that little negative [ __ ] Vibe on
my bed before no no no
or you're not the happy-go-lucky guy I
love seeing every week
no man I'm just deciding I are the
Giants due for a [ __ ] disappointing
loss dude against the Lions at home
I mean they beat the Texans the Texas oh
you're just stepping all over my [ __ ]
dance shoes this week
no every game you're talking about I was
taken go ahead Paul
you son of a [ __ ]
ah no but I don't like it
I don't like it oh they call them all
Paulie Hammond and Holland this week I
have to listen you [ __ ] talked about
the Patriots for three minutes to then
say you weren't touching the game Paul
people have to go to work
all right
um
no I like this week and now all of a
sudden they're changing Lines by half a
point because they know
they know Paulie like this week they
know that they know they work with sin
hey guys Paulie likes this week we gotta
change the lives
um all right dude
I'm gonna take the Los Angeles
um
all right dude I'm gonna take the Los
Angeles Chargers
I'm gonna take the Los Angeles Chargers
plus five and a half at home against the
Chiefs
um the Chiefs have been doing something
I noticed lately where they get off to
fast starts just like they did against
Jacksonville and then they kind of
[ __ ] go to sleep and they let teams
come back I think the Chargers are are
kind of have a little bit of a role
right now and I like the five and a half
at home I could see the Chiefs winning
towards the end and then the Chargers
getting a [ __ ] non-uh important
touchdown to make it close and beat the
book I got the charges to cover plus
five and a half in Los Angeles
all right
um
you took my [ __ ] cold spec
um
let's see here uh I actually like the
Giants minus three versus the Lions I
think the Lions
are a hapless organization they're a
family-run organization they're
everything that Giants aren't the Giants
from top to bottom are a class
organization that knows how to [ __ ]
win football games
and they've always been great with
defense it's only three points
um
the lights stink
I'm taking I'm taking your Giants Paul
I'm walking into your house Paul I'm
sitting down at your table and I'm
eating your [ __ ] food I'm taking your
Giants
what is it there's a wait is it three
and a half or three
it's three
okay it's [ __ ] three I should have
taken
um oh Vegas knew you weren't so they
kept it at three so my dumb ass would
take it but I'm gonna tell you what the
lock of the week is okay
I can't believe you didn't take in the
beginning coming off the lost on the
road coming off I'm actually gonna take
the road
Washington commanders minus three they
are flying right now they went into
Philly they won they're getting their
[ __ ] kill me don't tell me yeah
there's copycately Paul you're taking
all my teams this week whoa what
freaking all my teams this week I had
the commanders Monday night I called it
that they were going to win now you're
acting like it never happened like
Giuliani like you were the one who
cleaned up the city I see what you're
doing
oh he got it he's got to get some credit
for cleaning up the city I mean he went
on that pile he said no he didn't
[ __ ] commissioner it was Commissioner
Gordon cleaned it up and then he got rid
of him
and he was like it was all me
it was Dollar Tree
I'm gonna take the Washington commanders
minus three against the Texans the
Texans just they just defense is not
good they don't have a quarterback and
uh they uh the Washington commanders are
getting their defensive star back Chase
young the Ohio State Buckeye who [ __ ]
shot out of a cannon and then got hurt
real bad he's coming back I got
Washington minus three
you're out of your mind
you got to stay away from the Texans you
don't know who they are they're a
[ __ ] stripper you don't know what
they're gonna do they're gonna fall in
the ATM and they're gonna [ __ ] get a
razor under their tongue they're [ __ ]
crazy dude they're one eight and one or
one seven and one they stink I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about
against the spread oh
all right uh I'm gonna take the Panthers
just because they're getting 13 and a
half points and I figure the raisins are
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of them take
their foot off the gas and give them a
touchdown at the end of the [ __ ] game
to run down the clock and that's gonna
cover it
because nobody plays football pulse for
60 Minutes anymore that line moved from
yesterday bill from third to uh 13 and a
half to 13.
oh you know why because they knew I was
gonna take I'll give a [ __ ] I'll take 13
points
I'm gonna take the New Orleans Saints
minus three
Against The Reeling Cooper cupless Rams
I think that uh I don't love the Saints
but I don't love the Rams either I don't
trust the Rams for all he thinks the
Saints are Gonna Come Marching In
yeah I think the Rams are going to march
in there Rams all went to Applebee's
after that Super Bowl and I don't think
mentally they've come back I don't know
what's going I mean look injuries are
injuries
but uh
they are one of the most inconsistent
[ __ ] teams out there they're coming
off a brutal loss though Paul
yeah I don't I think
three
I don't like that game on the road in
the dome I like the Saints I think the
Rams no Cooper I love the Saints I love
New Orleans too
I hate these [ __ ] teams that they
just won't be who they are you know hey
Bill Bill oh When the Saints Go Marching
In and they cover for Paulie he's gonna
get a pair of Air Jordans and start
talking [ __ ] about the book
I'm seeing it now I see the game sorry
um all right here's my one crazy pick
for the [ __ ] week I don't know what
I'm gonna do here I might take the patch
laying three and a half but are they
gonna beat the Jets twice
is that really gonna happen Paul Jets
beat the bills I'm gonna stay away from
that game too Paul as much as I [ __ ]
[ __ ] on you and your gorgeous uh figure
skater uh hoodie
um I'm gonna uh stay away from that game
and uh
I don't know why but I'm gonna take the
Raiders get two and a half in Denver
with my old division rivalry which I've
heard you you're starting to come around
that fall you're coming to that church
of Jerusalem division rivalry games are
always close
um the Broncos with with with [ __ ] uh
Lando Calrissian is their quarterback
like nobody's [ __ ]
shooting to share with them they can't
text them
I just don't think that there's anything
going on in there the [ __ ] rate is
stink though
so does Denver though both of those
things thank you Denver stinks too who
won the who won that first game when
they played each other
um Andrew Broncos did they go into the
Raiders
um
I think it was a super close game but
well why did you take my Colts why did
you [ __ ] up my week and take my goddamn
Cults you know I'm not saying I don't
still love you but like I really took
that one personally
of all the things you've done to me over
the years Paul for you to take the
[ __ ] Cults in week 11. hey what have
I done all I've done to you over the
years is be a friend a loss in weeks uh
the Broncos lost in the week for uh to
uh the Raiders 23-32
all right [ __ ] that they're not they're
not gonna [ __ ] lose to him twice
they should but they won't because the
Raiders are the Raiders
all right so now what I have to do Paul
is I have to pull a game out of my ass
over here you also got to get back on
camera yeah I think you tap the uh hey
sometimes the mystery of it is what's
great you know what
is that is that Bill's Browns game still
seven and a half
the mystery
yes uh
I [ __ ] hate that game and I hate the
Bengals Steelers like who the [ __ ] knows
what's gonna happen there
um
you know what [ __ ] the Browns
the bills have came off a heartbreaking
loss
um
one in three written all over it this
[ __ ] week has one and three written
all over
Paulie throws a [ __ ] wrench in there
um
yeah it's the Browns why they have to be
seven and a half though
they're going to go into the prevent
[ __ ] me that's all right I'll take them
I'll take the bills you know Paul you
can catch up this week you know well let
me ask you real quick
thousand four hundred and fifty five
what does that mean to you one thousand
four hundred and fifty five uh
I just saw you in your high school
career anytime you got asked a question
you repeated the question to buy some
time knowing full well you didn't have
the answer
100 is the Pythagorean theorem
I know it I know it I know it
1455 the amount of times my wife broke
my balls oh okay
that's the last that's how many days
since I had a drink
oh my God
oh how sad is that dude I'm on day eight
no I'm on day 11 right now and I got to
tell you something dude you can't Being
Sober is the greatest thing ever man
it is Paul do you know why they say you
know when you're sober you know I slept
like a baby what it's because babies
don't drink and smoke cigars
they're they're like you know if you if
you're raising a baby right
it's straight edge it's completely sober
so what it's [ __ ] time the only thing
is they get mad because they don't
understand being tired but once they go
to bed that's that's it they're out
they're out like they're like that
sweaty head out
yeah that that oh that nap I know that
nap the little wet side the wetness
right here oh
dude you know my son doesn't want to get
up sometimes I go in there I get it and
I come walking and I'm like hey buddy
you want to get up and it just looks at
me for a second he goes
look all right
dude the more you the more I learn about
that kid the more dude my mom said her
girlfriends thought something was wrong
with me they're like didn't he go down
for a nap at 10 and then like woke up
like before dinner dude I dude I've been
down I like staying down
I play hard you know I play hard I rest
hard what can you do Andrew
[Laughter]
Paul baby baby Paul verzie would have
been the greatest thing ever oh dude
dude I was like one of the only kids
that didn't rush up on Christmas morning
I was I was like the presents aren't
going anywhere
my younger brother would be like he's
not coming they have it on camcorder
like the big camcorders they walked into
the bedroom it's pitch black and they go
come on I go huh I go you wanna go and
you just hear my younger brother go to
my parents he's not getting up
foreign
[Applause]
but you never did that [ __ ] you you too
you you get it you understand you
remember we were on your butt remember
we were on the bus tour
I'd wake up around 10 30 11 every day on
the bus tour and I'd wake up to here in
bartnick Burr and whoever else was on
the bus sitting up watching TV and I
would just walk into the main cabin and
they would just start laughing with the
look on my face you remember that
because dude you would get up at 11 30
and you look like somebody woke you up
at four in the morning
like I've never seen the guy like you
wake up dude there's an element of this
the only time of the day that you're
like visibly upset you say you look like
somebody happy to the fact that your
sleep time is over yeah I remember you
said to me once you go verzy why do you
look like somebody wronged you
yeah that's how you
I remember we did that tour through
Canada my whole [ __ ] thing was I
figured you out quick I was like Paul
has to make the first call of the day I
can't text him and ask what he wants
dude you were in the best mood every
place we stayed you came downstairs
you're like dude is it me
or was that the greatest bed you've ever
slept in in your life
and all it was was you got to sleep
until we were getting up to that was
such a [ __ ] great trip I I had a
little I had little babies at the time
they were really young and dude me and
you were together every day I believe 22
shows for 20 days 22 or 23 days we did
not fight one time because yeah we
figured each other that was when we
figured each other out bill was like all
right I'm gonna hear from verzie at 11.
so we'll go to lunch we just had it down
dude you gotta know you got the
Tendencies down I broke it down
and like Paul likes to [ __ ] sleep I
don't that's gonna be a problem leave
him alone let him text you let him call
you Paul that's that right there Paul
that's how that's how you [ __ ] stay
married that's that's that's what a
friendship is like I figured out my
wife's Tendencies I know the areas where
I enjoy her I still do most of them but
I do enough of them not anymore
I almost got lost in my own sentence
there
um
Bill you know what time it's Bill you
know what time it is oh [ __ ]
oh by the way I have to say this about
you my friend I have to say this about
you
okay I'll keep it to yourself
you're [ __ ] Washington Commander's
call not only forget the pick winning
forget the pick coming in okay because
that
dude you said why it would happen and
even though we didn't hit the Monday
night special because that [ __ ]
[ __ ] didn't throw a touchdown
everything else we had we had the over
we had the commanders he didn't throw
but people said dude I made some money
taking Washington great pick but Bill
you broke down you actually said on
camera Paulie not only do I think
they're gonna cover they could win this
[ __ ] game and then you said why and
that's what happened now I think they
could though
well what do you think this week bill
this week we got the Arizona where the
Patriots are undefeated you would just
go like you know I don't know man I mean
I think the Giants could surprise some
people today you hedged your bet so when
they did you were like what did I say
what did I use what did you say you said
they could maybe win today
I you know what's funny about that game
I remember I texted you I texted you
it's one of this is before we kind of
knew each other I texted you and you
talk about feeling each other's
Tendencies I started to learn about like
what to say with you with sports when
you don't know you versus what to say
with you when you do know you and I just
go dude the Giants came to play today
and you just texted back Paul it's the
Super Bowl and I [ __ ] almost fell
down laughing
I tell you what bill they look like
they're really into this game they
really look like they're into the Super
Bowl
I know
um I bet whole [ __ ] season was the
most overhyped
Sports change that year
oh [ __ ] where's the line go hold on all
right Bill we got this fans go what are
you talking about they were undefeated
and I always say we played each other
last game of the year we won on the last
play I was at that game dude that was 36
to like 33 and then no it was 38. 11
Point whatever the [ __ ] it was you know
what I mean yeah it was dude oh my God
can you believe that team and it took
him [ __ ] four pointers to beat won
the game
[Laughter]
dude if we were like 17-1 going into
that and then we lost two we're just
been a great Super Bowl
that's true it's true it is it is true
and it's also true that all these
[ __ ] stupid quarterbacks now none of
them know how to run the two-minute
offense because you don't need to know
how to run a [ __ ] two-minute offense
when you get a 20-yard cushion and
they're not even guarding Sidelines and
you're getting free 20 yard first down
timeouts the whole [ __ ] way down the
field
the [ __ ] am I doing taking the bills I
should have stayed with the ratings
what do you think Bill we got the 49ers
going Arizona Cardinals
what'd you say oh [ __ ] the Cardinals
they had their Super Bowl last week you
know they beat the Applebee Rams
the line is eight though the line's
eight
the line is eight ah I know the number
is just
division rivalry games are usually close
what happened the first time they played
um I think the Niners won or or is this
the first meeting
it's November I bet it's the second It's
gotta be
you never know sometimes they have a
weird schedule where they [ __ ]
November December of
dude I was talking on my podcast dude
Thanksgiving is overrated
it's [ __ ] overrated
you know Paul I think your part you say
some dumb [ __ ] like that no it is it is
it's it's um the more I get older the
more I actually don't like it as much
it's still good but it's not I mean I
can't even touch I mean it's not even
close to any other other big ones
hold on let me tell you why there's only
one other big one
it's Christmas what are you gonna throw
Halloween in there no Easter's Easter
Sundays you know I mean but Easter
Sunday is I guess it's Sunday no no but
but in the usfla [ __ ] holidays
I think this Sunday is a joke that's
like
I mean if I got nothing by my power
rankings they're slightly ahead of Flag
Day
[Laughter]
[Music]
you want to know your Sunday no you know
what I guess as long as [ __ ] mess
where they go all through the Psalms
Palm Sunday and everybody walks out I
[ __ ] hate From the Ashes to the
[ __ ] pubs
well I hate that whole [ __ ] period
This is my problem why don't you give up
raping boys you [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey all right all right uh uh what the
[ __ ] is wrong with thanks you don't have
to buy any gifts no here's the thing
with Thanksgiving eat great food
Thanksgiving watch your relatives fight
with each other if you're above it
because but the reason why people will
fight on Thanksgiving is Thanksgiving is
a holiday where some people that you
really sometimes don't love
dude if you come to my house on
Christmas or Christmas Eve I have to
love you I have until this happened no
no if you come to my house with soothing
sounds of easy listening and then you
just started screaming no Thanksgiving
is a thing you go to my [ __ ] house
you went Dick Gregory on me no no no if
you're gonna be around my children and
my house on Christmas okay
I love you you know what I mean I have
to love you to be at my house on
Christmas love true love tell me how
much about your immediate family
Thanksgiving you got somebody there that
you [ __ ] never see the whole year and
they could say something [ __ ] dumb
and you're just sitting there with a
fake smile can't wait till the [ __ ]
those people leave where you could be
with the people you really want to be
with and that's not my experience on
Thanksgiving Paul because those people
don't get an invite if you're a [ __ ]
you're not coming to my table that's on
you you're blaming the holiday but it's
on you I'm not saying oh you're gonna be
back through your own table you gotta be
master of your own table
take away football take away football on
Thanksgiving it's over it's [ __ ] the
day's over why
if you took the NFL away on Thanksgiving
what do you got you're sitting around
there with uh yeah all right take away
[ __ ] presents on Christmas what do
you got a bunch of people standing
around a [ __ ] tree ah dude you got
the lights you got the tree you got the
[ __ ] songs dude Silent Night are you
out of your [ __ ] mind dude Silent
Night is the first of all what did I say
about Silent Night why are you saying
I'm out of my [ __ ] mind what do you
mean
no no I'm saying lady what are your
[ __ ] mind you jumped into that like I
just said Silent Night sucked
no you said a tree and everything you're
completely forget no great music
The Amazing Music is for insane people
no no it's for happy people man it's a
[ __ ] festive time
it's a festive time
because you're sitting here you're
trying to yell at me about your
festivities no you're trying to put
Thanksgiving on the same [ __ ] level
as Christmas
you just you said it was overrated
you just said I like Christmas better
you know we wouldn't be yelling at each
other I'm starting to dislike
Thanksgiving the older I get
you know what it is pop
you have a couple of people that you
shouldn't invite and you don't have the
balls to uninvitable
hey it's my wife Italian it's all about
food hey it's my wife's fault okay
certain things I gotta hold in okay
it's that you're actually that's that's
right I got an idea when that person
says what they're gonna say
to wrote another Thanksgiving just have
a bell and just be like
there it is
did you feel it we were all having a
good time
yeah and then you give her like the
turnover chain or something like that
the [ __ ] you didn't put it around her
neck
all right and then she's just a [ __ ]
idiot for the rest of this because I
love that it's like the jerk-off chain
or something like that dude I love that
you just seeing a loudmouth Uncle with a
big [ __ ] thing around his neck and
the guy it was me
yeah it's all like bedazzled I ruined it
foreign
well you gotta do that
you got to get a bell you gotta get the
chain It's gotta say I ruined it I
ruined Thanksgiving dude dude you Bill
when me and when me and Bill first when
when I would confide in Bill about my
relationship early because I was one of
the young you know younger Comics to
have a family I would call Bill and go
dude dude here's the one thing I don't
know if you remember this I go here's
the one thing I go Christmas Eve it's my
nobody's [ __ ] I said it early to my
wife I go Christmas Eve I hold just
because of things when I was younger my
parents when they were divorced we would
go to my grandmother's it was the
greatest night of my life Christmas Eve
I don't compromise Christmas Eve
Christmas Eve
okay so now you have Christmas Eve so
now what you have to do is what all
powerful countries do you now have to do
an overreach this is like when Germany
went into Austria you have to take
Thanksgiving
okay you gotta you gotta you gotta
create
some sort of some you gotta You Gotta
Have Fun
dude do you remember you sent me those
Cubans dude you gave me a memory I'm
gonna tell you something about what you
did you gave me a memory on thanks on
Christmas Eve once where I just just the
timing of the day that it was in the
mail whatever happened you sent me
Cubans and they literally showed up to
the house
and my older brother's there my younger
brother's there it was Christmas [ __ ]
Eve and we opened this package and it's
Cubans and it was from you and me my
older brother younger brother went
outside and we smoked a Cuban on
Christmas Eve and I'm probably like at
least three four whiskeys in wine and I
just was like this is the greatest and
and none of those people would [ __ ]
have been at my house on the on on that
were there on Thanksgiving well why
don't you invite him on Thanksgiving
your team yeah
and then you just run it down their
throats this is what you do this whoever
the [ __ ] is Paul you get that
Tendencies down
and then what you do is you just say
things that irritate them
and then that becomes the game within
the game I have a buddy of mine
his mother-in-law is is a narcissist and
it used to drive him nuts but now you
know what he does this is for anybody
out there we all deal with narcissists
this is the way you handle them you know
what he does he overly he starts overly
complimenting one of her friends
and it drives the Mother-in-law [ __ ]
nuts I mean it's it's one of the it's
like that
one of the greatest things that I have
ever heard that is psychological warfare
he does it to her
oh it's so great well say her name's
Gail we'll be like Gail I have to tell
you something
your friend Susan has got to be one of
the nicest people and he won't shut up
he won't shut up until she like [ __ ]
has to walk away and when she comes back
he keeps bringing it up and it it
becomes like [ __ ] repellent like she
won't go near him
um that dude that's like the most genius
thing I've ever heard
yeah
I'm gonna tell you right now Paul all
the [ __ ] winners we picked this year
that's that's the [ __ ] gift of the
year right there how to handle a [ __ ]
narcissist because they're literally
mentally ill people that can hold down a
[ __ ] job wipe their ass and pay their
taxes so we have to interact with them
because you can't stick them in a loony
bin and you just have to [ __ ] deal
with these people that's [ __ ] great
dude yeah and they don't want to come
near you and talk to you because it's
something that they don't want to hear
that's fantastic right now here's the
thing
you know if you can't you have to cut
all the narcissists out of your life you
just have to do it
which I've done at this point you know
yeah
yeah which is tough because sometimes it
can be a family member
no that's yeah that's that's the other
thing too you know
I don't do that Italian thing
it's [ __ ] family if you're an [ __ ]
dude cement shoes right over you're
right over the [ __ ] side
no yeah Life's too short to not
especially in the holidays
yeah Paul so here's the deal we found
out what the real problem is it's not
Thanksgiving
it's not that Paul you I mean who who
doesn't like to eat who doesn't like to
sit down deal with your little glass of
grape juice there's no way you're
wearing that white hoodie I'll say right
that on Thanksgiving no [ __ ] away oh
no I get you wear that you wear that on
Christmas Eve sorry I'm looking like a
[ __ ] snowman out there you would not
do that on Thanksgiving
um you're coming there in some autumn
colors
you know what it is Paul you can already
see it in your face it's like you're
walking into the building
you're anticipating a loss you're not
going there to win
I want you to win this Thanksgiving call
dude I'm not gonna lie Thanksgiving I'm
always in a prevent defense
prevent defense Bill I just
I
just
dude I think the turnover chain that
says like you turned it over from a good
time to a bad time and it just says I
ruined Thanksgiving
is so [ __ ] silly everybody's gonna
laugh no one's gonna give a [ __ ] what
the person said
the Bell some sort of
[ __ ] weird something from a joke shop
uh that's [ __ ] dude that's so [ __ ]
funny
um all right so are we gonna take the
Niners given given eight that's a
[ __ ] I mean we could but um
where's the game
the game is in Arizona the under over is
43 and a half I take Arizona
take the points because the 49ers will
kick the [ __ ] out of them and then
they'll just [ __ ] go into a prevent
they'll get a [ __ ] you hear you
they're gonna make a wish touchdown
and they haven't played yet this year
you would ask before they haven't played
yet what do we think about the under
over 43 and a half
I think this game's gonna be boring
yeah under
all right
so now we only have one other question
so we're going to take Arizona plus
eight we're gonna take under
43 and a half
do we do Jimmy G to throw one or do we
do
Christianity
we're not going to bet on an Italian
here
yes we are
yes we are
come here you
go menu great point my my fault my fault
good looking Italian David you're
already anticipating a loss on
Thanksgiving Paul you're not you're not
you're not thinking clearly here
listen you got to get me to December get
me to December I go on a win streak
that's such a sicilian part of you
what yeah that Thanksgiving is dead to
you no no it's not dead to me it's just
not my favorite anymore it's not it oh
[ __ ] let me tell you something we get
the [ __ ] eggnog going right me and my
wife we I taped the game we watched the
[ __ ] uh the Westminster Dog Show
we had back-to-back years we picked the
[ __ ] uh the winner I the one year the
Bloodhound won it was just like it was
over I mean the [ __ ] yeah it was
gorgeous well here's my question who
comes to your house on Thanksgiving
who's how many people are in the group
hey Paul I'm mastering my tape
I have nothing but cool ass people come
to my table this is a great thing when
you're in your 50s like when somebody
has nowhere to go on Thanksgiving it's
because they're an [ __ ]
yeah yes and I don't like that person
coming I don't like that I don't I don't
like this
who's in town for the [ __ ] weekend
coming in eating my stuffing no and I
got a [ __ ] family member I got a
[ __ ] family member
oh we got trouble right here in River
City yeah we got to talk about it
because I don't have enough [ __ ]
seats for you dude don't get me started
because I got a family member that oh
they had nowhere to give and you want
can they come there's a reason no that's
the [ __ ] that's uh I'm actually
stepping on bartnick's homeless show
you're almost for a reason yeah you're
an [ __ ] if you don't have a couch if
somebody's gonna pick her up on the
couch
it's a great joke
uh this game is in Mexico City it's not
in Arizona
oh
and also the Niners of the I mean I
think they're top rated I think their
defense is like number one right now so
uh
yeah but Arizona's gonna come and want
to play good in that in that environment
too the eight points is good
do you want to change everything is
pointing towards you take the [ __ ]
49ers and that's why that's why Vegas
wins no and you know what I I like
Arizona like on a big showcase night
like that to kind of [ __ ] division
rival man I like it I like I gotta go
down there and a couple players they're
gonna do something stupid they're gonna
party a little bit and I think that's
gonna work in the uh
the [ __ ] Cardinals favor dude back in
the day you could guarantee that now the
NFL's run like a a dictatorship dude you
want to know what it is I just figured
it out dude I want to know what it is
these people go like this they go hey we
just thought it would be nice to have
them they didn't have Thanksgiving and
they want to be the [ __ ] they want
the people there so they look like I
brought them so you know what they do
they go to work and tell people yeah we
didn't know that they didn't have
anybody we brought them there
to keep driving
hahaha
yeah there's always somebody if yeah if
Planes Trains and Automobiles there's a
real movie [ __ ] uh Steve Martin would
have popped the bottle of champagne when
he finally got on that train and said
I'm out of this [ __ ] nightmare and
left them at the train station
great movie though by the way John Candy
Legend it's a great movie all right so
there you go guys so Jimmy G's gonna
throw one Jimmy G's gonna throw one
we're gonna go oh is he gonna run one in
Paul that counts right either way Jimmy
G5 we gotta be specific
we got to be specific yeah he's not
going to run one he'll he does he's not
he's a throw he's going to throw one
and he's got he's got the weapons to
throw it to too so all right so Jimmy G
to throw one under 43 and a half and
we're gonna take the Arizona Cardinals
getting
a snowman getting eight yes
um all right well there you go we got
our picks here you got our picks there's
a guy going down the river in literally
what looks like a box
like there's nothing aerodynamic it
floats
I don't know what though I'm in
Jacksonville man [ __ ] gets gets a little
wild out here all right that's the
Monday night special
that's the anything better
hey Bill what are you doing for
breakfast today are you going eggs Benny
or are you going omelette what's going
on over there
don't go to the gym and then after the
gym I'll probably get like an apple or
not hey Bill you're gonna have a gator
omelet I'm telling you man with the eggs
it tastes just like chicken no it
doesn't tastes like a [ __ ] reptile
all right guys well listen I just want
to tell you I'm going to take this phone
call have a good Friday
um all right everybody well there you go
that was mine and Bill's picks for uh
NFL Week number 11. I can't believe how
this season is dude I can't believe that
this season is is is going as fast as
it's going but we want to let everybody
know that we're having such a great time
with bed MGM and we want you to get
involved and we want to make you some
money uh we know that this Monday
night's uh special year we've we've been
close we're gonna try to get one for you
at least one
um but make sure man the way to use the
BET MGM app it's very simple all you got
to do is uh go to the App Store and
download and get the BET MGM app all you
have to do is put in bonus code Burr
that's b-u-r-r it's very very simple you
could put as little as ten dollars in
the account and you get up to a thousand
dollars in free bets even if the BET
loses is just make sure you put in bonus
code Burr that's b-u-r-r you can go on
the app and when you click on the NFL
you will see the Monday night special
anything better on the site click on
that and ride with us with whatever you
know Monday night special you put a
little money on there and and hopefully
we make you some money with that
um also this is the other thing too
Andrew that people could do if they were
like hey I love their pick with the
points on the Monday night special
uh but I don't know if I love the under
over you could actually I mean even
though it wouldn't be part of our thing
you could go hey I like Bill and Paul's
because that's what somebody said about
the Commandments build your own bet yeah
yeah that's what somebody said about the
somebody said about the actually I'm
glad we're talking about this because
people we never talked about this before
people reached out to us and go hey
thank you guys for picking the
commanders against the Eagles I went
with that and they won money so they
didn't necessarily have to do the under
over and the other thing for our thing
but they could go hey I went with that
and we did make some people some money
with the commanders so if there's some
listen there's sometimes I like a part
of our Monday night special but I'm a
hesitant on the other
um so uh you can do it that way uh as
well
um dude yesterday this is a little
inside baseball we'll give uh to the to
just a couple minutes over time I gotta
hey I gotta get out of here my wife's
home
um I talked to Andrew yesterday you
remember and I go hey dude I go
because this is coming out just a little
bit late 12 hours later we weren't able
to we weren't able to uh record we
weren't able to record yesterday with
like traveling stuff so this is coming
out basically 12 hours later or whatever
than it normally would but I said to
Andrew I go dude I go
the Packers are coming off a win they're
home I know I'm staying away from them
the lion is three I go I don't know if I
would have picked them should I and then
I actually talked myself out of it with
you I go you know something though I go
they still got to prove it like I can't
you know it is the Titans the Titans are
a good team and then I'm driving to the
city last night and I'm listening on the
radio and they're like Packers down 10
late in the fourth and I'm going woof
so uh I and dude I heard the Packers
need to either run the table to have a
chance so I think it's pretty much over
for the I think it's over for Green Bay
well I mean you mean for the year of
course yeah I mean there's no there's no
there's no the only there's no momentum
nobody's yeah no the the only the only
window the Packers would have is to run
the table from now until week 18. and I
don't think that they they just clearly
don't have the power to do that
um yeah some games that you guys didn't
cover uh and Bill almost took the
Raiders I I mean that's that that team
is in shambles I mean they like that
that team was pronounced dead last week
dude I'm gonna yeah it's funny you said
and the Broncos also I've maintained
since like week four I mean three
anyways I mean I they this bill I think
maybe saw a little bit of Russell
Wilson's past and his present thinking
like oh but he's not he's he's he's
terrible with this team I mean he's
terrible with this team and it's not all
his fault but
he he gets at least a third no he it is
a little bit of his fault because when
you're not giving your own teammates
your phone number when you're when your
teammates are asking for your phone
number and you're going talk to my
people and that's the guy that you got
to be protecting and that's the guy
that's your [ __ ] I said on I said on
good morning football I said he's the
new Ellen you know uh and and that's you
can't have that but I agree with you I
think that well look I'm four and a half
games back right I'm four and a half
games back of this thing and take away
my Packers picks and my Raiders picks
and I'm probably somewhere right there
but I believed that I believe that Aaron
Rodgers Aaron [ __ ] Rogers who still
can throw it the way he could throw it I
believe that they were gonna do
something I was wrong about that
um when you say do something you just
mean win a few of these games or you
mean like be a playoff Contender yeah no
I mean like these games that I pick
against the spread you know I mean dude
there was a game where I picked the
Packers and I think they were dogs like
they like the Packers were dogs against
a team they couldn't and and should be
like a year ago and they just can't now
um it just goes to show dude like you
need you you know and listen man it it's
never good dude it's never good this is
one thing that that
uh I think people need to
you know and I think people know it but
need to pay attention to
when your quarterback is in the news a
lot for things other than football okay
I don't care what it is I don't care if
it's a domestic dispute I don't care if
it's a political view I don't care if
it's whatever it is but when you're
quarterback especially when your
quarterback is publicly criticizing the
organization he plays for when you start
seeing those things when you start
seeing a guy that's been a staple go
yeah well you know I mean listen if we
could get a good offensive game plan and
all that correct shot all that comes
down to is that like literally it all
just comes down to are you executing
plays and that's why Belichick is the
way he is because everything is within
he draws a circle around himself and his
team right and it's just like everything
on the other side of that line
everything else has nothing to do with
what he's talking about he doesn't care
he doesn't care about anything else he's
hyper focused and he's hyper Vigilant at
the task at hand that's that's all of
that is
a reduction of every Quirk that
Belichick has is just that's what it is
now has there have there been times
where maybe that's either backfired uh
or maybe that like line of thinking is
what led him to wanting to trade Brady
and keep Jimmy G like I don't I don't
know like you know that that's gossip
stuff but
um
yeah so uh as far as that goes yeah you
can't have a quarterback in the news
because you because I agree with that
it's outside the lines you can't go
outside
I agree with that I like that analogy
too of like inside the circle and then
outside of it doesn't make sense like
yeah think about think about this dude
Russell Wilson who like is not on great
terms with the team while they're
sleeping on the airplane going to London
he's exercising up and down the aisles
doing high knees up and down the aisles
trying to like and dude that like those
guys are going like what the [ __ ] is
this guy like when you start hearing
[ __ ] like that you know what Russell
Wilson needs to be doing on an airplane
going to London he needs to be playing
[ __ ] cards with his offensive line
laughing and being like hey dude when we
get to London do dinner on me and let's
[ __ ] be a family and let's go [ __ ]
show the NFL that we're here that's what
a guy needs to do and and when you do
things like that you're like oh I'll die
for that dude you know I'll [ __ ] die
for that dude you know to put it this
way if I'm gonna say this dude if if
Paul verzie was an NFL quarterback those
I would have those got dude those guys I
would be buying [ __ ] dude my offense my
Center would just show up to his mansion
and there would just be a Rolls-Royce
there and there'd be a [ __ ] sticker
on a window from me that said thank you
yeah I mean like it's like you say that
and then you start thinking like am I
gonna buy this guy at Rolls-Royce I mean
like he could roll his ankle next week
and then I gotta buy the new well no
yeah probably not a Rolls-Royce but like
I know I'm just saying I would probably
yeah no I would go maybe like not
Roosevelt
you don't know maybe like the new
electric BMW something you know
something like nice little toy for my
you know yeah
um you get them and eat a big car
yeah you know I'm gonna but here's what
I'm interested in if I can fight back in
this and fight back and crawl to 500 in
the next couple of weeks hopefully knock
on wood and still have had those Packer
losses
um I'll be all right I'm happy that bill
is above 500 by half a game
and uh I have some work to do to crawl
back but I look at it like this I was
eight games back two weeks ago I was
eight games back and right now I'm four
and a half now I don't know I could have
a bad week maybe not we'll see but um I
hope everybody is enjoying these and um
I mean I think the Philly Colts I think
that's probably the craziest one uh
yeah uh my Phillies Colts is crazy
especially Philly coming off of a
everybody's nothing about the Colts
there's nothing about the Colts that are
gonna overwhelm the Eagles well there's
one thing
it's not easy seven and a half it's six
and a half there's there's one thing
about the Cults that I like and it's
that they're running back Jonathan
Taylor is really starting to come back
and get a Groove and I also saw how the
Washington commanders just ran against
the Eagles and they ran down there
You Gotta Lose once I said you know
Patriots had probably one of their best
years I think it was 2000 and it was the
the second Super Bowl
uh and we we uh I think we lost to like
oh I'm blank and I believe it was like
week two or three the Texans
and I remember people going like oh man
you know and it's just like and then you
look at that whole year and it's like we
never should have lost to that team you
know what I mean like you never should
have lost to that team uh maybe it was
the Titans maybe not it was even around
and uh I could tell you that I could
tell you this my Colts pick is either
going to be really bad or really good I
think they're either going to get blown
out or it's going to be like [ __ ] that
was a good one but listen man I gotta
shake it up I gotta get back no no no
yeah yeah so there you guys that that
this has been um the preview for week
11. I I'm kind of sad that we're six
weeks away from the NFL almost being
seven weeks away from the NFL being over
which is like I feel like it just
started and um hey my Giants are seven
and two Andrew that's fun that's fun you
got something you got you gotta end of
the season you know do you now here
here's my last question for you before
we get out of here sure
um
do you think
that the Patriots beat the Jets minus
three and a half in in um New England or
no
um I actually think we win this game
outright money line I don't know about I
I I do it by three and a half is tough
we win by two or three yeah I mean I
wish I don't that's not even
I don't know I don't know we we could
win by two we could win by ten I don't
know I just think we win I think we last
second field goal last second field goal
by one could see that
yeah yeah I mean that's why like I don't
was that's I would never on this game I
would never take I would never go
against that three and a half I would
just take money line if I was you know
if I was taking that game this week yeah
yeah I think they went yeah no I I think
the Patriots win the game I just didn't
like that half a point they're the same
team they're we they're both week to
week teams I mean it's like the five and
four jets are six and three I mean it's
not like you know Pats could have won
one of those games in there and easily
been six and three so
yeah I think the Jets because they suck
so much and it seems like they've been
playing you know fairly well considering
what they have you know and they've won
some big games it seems like they're
better than they are because they've
sucked the patriots feel like they're
doing worse because they're usually like
at least contenders anyways that's my
thing actually that's actually a really
good point it's like the Jets are
playing good they're playing good
defense they're winning some games but
for the Jets it looks even better
because they're they're kind of almost
you feel like it's a rebuild with the
new coach and all that stuff and then
with the Patriots you've just been such
a staple in the NFL for the last 20
years that when they're when there's
even a little bit of a dip and no Brady
you're like oh [ __ ] so
um somebody said something recently it
was uh LeSean McCoy Shady McCoy uh and
he said that he thinks Bill Belichick is
and without Brady he's an under 500
Coach and like he goes he's listening he
goes he's a good coach but he goes with
Brady he's what he was he goes I don't
think he's that good I didn't
necessarily agree with that that's
[ __ ] anytime I hear that stat that's
[ __ ] when you say that somebody won
if they had one quarterback for 20 years
of their career and then you take the
average of quarter of the average that
any coach has in his career of a good
quote having like like a star
quarterback it might be one out of five
so now Belichick needs to coach two or
three more quarterbacks right you know
considering he had blood soap for a
little bit and then Brady and then now
we'll just you know
I guess this is where we're at now we
haven't really had too many in between
I'm not going to count uh what's his
face but uh yeah so I I think it's like
yeah well if he has six more
quarterbacks and he can't happen in 20
years then maybe you could say yeah he's
only 500 but right now with with the
20-year quarterback he's like well he's
done he's under 500 without Brady it's
because he's been with Brady the whole
time what kind of stupid stat is that I
love that I love that you're 100 right
and that's like saying oh well what
would Bill Walsh do rest his soul if he
wasn't with Joe Montana for all those
pictures yeah it's like it's not fair to
say that a guy figured out a system with
a guy and they worked together great and
then all of a sudden one of those pieces
leaves they go well he's not that good
it's like it's it is kind of [ __ ]
it's kind of some hate and [ __ ]
um all right everybody all right we are
done this has been week 11 preview me
and uh The Greek Freak give you a little
over time give you a little inside
baseball on the thought process on where
we are right now we think it's kind of
cool some of the fans mentioned that
they liked it so you know what we'll
[ __ ] around not gonna do this every time
but you know we'll talk a little [ __ ] I
hope everybody enjoys uh this is the
um oh this is the last week before the
Thanksgiving games my Giants are playing
the Cowboys on Thanksgiving in Dallas uh
oh that gives me the willies even
thinking about I'll get into that next
week enjoy uh enjoy your week bet
responsibly download the app bonus code
burr Put in as little as 10 bucks you
get up to a thousand enjoy everybody and
we will see you next week and remember
guys to bet you got to be 21 years of
age or older to wager in Arizona
Colorado DC Iowa Indiana Kansas Michigan
Mississippi New Jersey New York Nevada
Pennsylvania Tennessee
uh Virginia West Virginia or Wyoming
only new customer offer paid in free
bets visit betmgm.com for terms and
conditions uh excludes Michigan
disassociated persons uh please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step for Arizona call
1-800-522-4700 for Colorado DC Nevada
Wyoming West Virginia
1-800-270-7117 for confidential help
Michigan
1-800 Gambler in Indiana New Jersey
Pennsylvania and West Virginia
1-800 bets off in Iowa call or text the
Tennessee Red Line
800-889-9789 in Tennessee or call
1-88-77-9696 for Mississippi sports
betting is void in Georgia Hawaii Ohio
and Utah and other states were
prohibited
promotional offers not available in
Nevada
[Applause]
[Music]